.
(indicatif musical)
bon matin. Donc ici de Montréal
au centre de l'information nous
allons vous présenter toute la
matinée ce début de campagne
électorale. 40 jours de
campagne, une campagne beaucoup
plus courte cette année. Nous
connaissions depuis quatre ans
la date de l'élection. Le
scrutin et le 21 octobre.
Monsieur Trudeau a décidé
aujourd'hui de déclencher à 10
heures les élections. Il sera
chez la gouverneur général où il
demandera la dissolution de la
chambre des communes. Commencera
à ce moment-là la campagne
électorale. Les chefs auront
droit à des visibilités égales.
Une fois que la campagne est
déclenchée, Monsieur Trudeau
reste premier ministre mais il
est surtout candidat, chef
libéral. Andrew Sheer est chef
conservateur. Ils auront dans
les médias canadiens à peu près
le même traitement, traitement
équitable. 40 jours pour vous
faire une idée. C'est important.
On l'a beaucoup souligné depuis
plusieurs mois, les campagne
électorale change la donne
aujourd'hui. Si c'est important.
C'est un exercice démocratique.
Daniel Thibault attend le
premier ministre va faire son
entrée dans quelques minutes.
Racontez-nous un peu comment ça
va se passer.
- C'est un rituel qui n'est pas
nouveau. Il y a d'autres
premiers ministres qui l'ont
traversé. On voit derrière
l'entrée principale de Rideau
Hall. Monsieur Trudeau devrait
arriver flanquer d'une trentaine
de partisans. Il va rencontrer
Julie Payette la gouverneur
général. La façon dont ça se
déroule et ça fait parti de la
tradition, il y a trois
éléments. Monsieur Trudeau va
soumettre sa demande pour la
dissolution de la chambre des
communes.
- On le voit déjà. Sera-t-il
plus tôt? Il va reconduire à
l'école les enfants.
- La marche dans le parc. Il
n'est pas très loin. Depuis que
Monsieur Trudeau a décidé de ne
pas loger aux 24 Sussux, sa
résidence officielle et sur le
terrain de Rideau Hall.
On nous dit qu'il devrait être
ici aux environs de 10 heures ce
matin. Mme Payette va signer des
documents. Une pour la
dissolution et la dernière pour
prévoir le retour. Ça fait parti
de l'exercice constitutionnel.
Quand tout ça est signé, une
trentaine de minutes, Monsieur
Trudeau va ressortir par la
porte principale et il va venir
à un podium installé à ma droite
ici où il répondra aux questions
des journalistes. C'est à ce
moment-là qu'on va faire
référence, on va dire de lui
qu'il est le chef libéral même
s'il demeure premier ministre.
Quand c'est terminé ici, il sort
dans la voiture et va à
l'aéroport pour commencer la
campagne électorale.
- Monsieur Trudeau souhaite un
deuxième mandat. Règle générale,
les Canadiens redonnent un
second mandat. Parfois
minoritaire. On n'a qu'à penser
au père de Monsieur Trudeau qui
était rentré grandement 1968 et
a eu un gouvernement minoritaire
en 1972. Les choses ont changé
le temps s'accélèrent. Ce qui
était vrai dans le passé n'est
pas garant automatiquement pour
lui d'un second mandat. Le défi
pour Monsieur Trudeau reste
énorme. Il ne peut pas perdre
beaucoup de députés s'il veut
garder le pouvoir et la
majorité.
- Non. Voilà. C'est intéressant
parce que cette campagne on
connaît la date depuis un bout
de temps. On sait depuis quatre
ans que l'élection aura lieu le
21 octobre. Il y avait une
fenêtre pour déclencher la
campagne. Décision stratégique
de la déclencher aujourd'hui. Il
avait jusqu'au 15 septembre pour
le faire. Les stratèges libéraux
semblent penser qu'ils peuvent
capitaliser sur la glissade du
vote néon et baccarat entre
autres au Québec pour compenser
certaines pertes anticipées dans
les provinces atlantiques. Quand
vous parlez aux libéraux et
conservateurs ont mise beaucoup
sur l'Ontario. Et il y a les
batailles à trois ou à quatre
sur la côte ouest. On n'en
parlera plus tard mes Monsieur
Trudeau quand l'élection sera
déclenchée il quittera
directement pour la côte ouest.
Il y a des batailles
intéressants qui se dessinent
là-bas. Ce qu'on me disait aussi
c'est que dès qu'il a terminé
Vancouver, il revient au Québec
assez rapidement parce qu'on
veut montrer que le Québec est
important. On mise beaucoup sur
les gains à faire au Québec.
Tout le monde dans les
organisation libérale nous en
parle depuis plusieurs mois. On
espère aller chercher une
quinzaine de circonscriptions ou
plus au Québec. C'est ce qui
pourrait permettre au
gouvernement, à Monsieur
Trudeau, d'aller chercher ce
second mandat.
- On va montrer les données au
point de départ de cette course
à la dissolution dans quelques
secondes. Le nombre de députés
que chaque partie détient
actuellement. Pas le même nombre
que lors de la soirée électorale
en 2015. Il y a eu des
démissions et des départs. Les
libéraux partent avec 177 ce
matin
et Monsieur Bernier représente
son parti populaire canadien.
Avec moi tout au long de la
matinée pour cette émission
spéciale, Alec Castonguay, Josée
Legault et Asha Kheiriddin.
Tour de table rapide. On vient
de voir les forces en présence.
L'histoire est du côté d'un
second mandat de Monsieur
Trudeau, mais l'histoire n'est
plus la même non plus. Le temps
est changeant. On l'a vu partout
sur la planète.
- Au Canada depuis les années 30
on a toujours eu un deuxième
mandat. Mais vous savez,
l'accélération, les gens se
tendent, ils veulent du
changement, il y a cette force
qui joue contre Justin Trudeau.
Le désir d'avoir quelque chose
de différent. Une campagne
électorale c'est un référendum
sur le gouvernement sortant. Ils
doivent se demander s'ils
veulent réélire le gouvernement
en place et en regard des
alternatives. Pour l'instant je
pense que les gens n'ont pas
vraiment la tête aux élections.
Nous on aime ça, mais les
candidats médisaient sur le
terrain qu'il y a 50 % des
portes où ils frappent, ils
n'ont pas idée que la campagne
électorale commence.
- Ça va s'accentuer à chaque
fois. Cette campagne est plus
courte.
- Ça peut bouger assez
rapidement. J'ai confiance que
les gens vont vraiment
s'intéresser parce qu'il va y
avoir quand même des on dit
qu'il n'y a pas de grands
projets. Mais il y a des visions
très différentes qui vont être
présentées par Justin Trudeau,
qui a une vision plus
collective, plus tourné vers
l'avenir. Il dit qu'il choisit
de ne pas reculer. Qui recule?
Les conservateurs bien entendus.
Et le message des conservateurs
est plus individualiste. Il dit
qu'il va mettre de l'argent dans
nos poches. Pas pour le
collectif. Et aussi on voit les
autres messages qui vont se
décliner pendant le temps d'en
parler. Il y aura un choix de
vision quand même.
- On va l'entendre dès ce matin
parce qu'il y aura les discours
les points de presse des
différents chefs qu'on va vous
présenter ce matin. Monsieur
Trudeau est le premier à aller
devant les journalistes et on va
entendre les six chefs, même
Monsieur Bernier qui est à
Toronto.
- Il y a quand même de vision,
au moins deux visions qui
s'affrontent.
- Je suis pas d'accord que c'est
contre le collectif que Andrew
Sheer se présente. C'est contre
les élites. Ça va bénéficier
potentiellement conservateurs
mais aussi au verre. Il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont
frustrés avec les parties
traditionnelles un peu à la
François Legault comme au
Québec. Vont-ils choisir Mme May
par exemple. Si c'est
l'environnement le sujet, c'est
un couteau à double tranchant
pour Monsieur Trudeau. En
Colombie Britannique puisqu'il a
approuvé TransMountain, ça va
jouer contre lui. Et au Québec
aussi les gens sont très
conscients de l'environnement.
Moi je regarde les Verts. C'est
le parti le plus intéressant de
cette élection.
- On se demande si le NPD va
survivre.
- C'est pour ça qu'ils sont en
chicane présentement on voit des
défections Nouveau-Brunswick des
gens qui sont partis du NPD au
Parti vert. Je pense que la
chicane sur le côté progressiste
est intéressante aussi.
- Sur le terrain on sera avec
les chefs tout au long de la
campagne. Il y a des enjeux
qu'on va décortiquer. Il y a
l'épreuve des faits. Est-ce
qu'il dise la vérité? Tout au
long de la campagne, mais c'est
important de ne pas oublier ça,
les Canadiens veulent savoir ce
qu'ils ont dans le ventre.
Prendre la mesure des capacités
intellectuelles stratégiques et
émotives des chefs. Tout au long
de la campagne les journalistes
que vous voyez vont les suivre
sur le terrain et nous tenons
être là présents. Ça coûte une
fortune, oui, mais c'est
important que les journalistes
soient là et puissent poser des
questions en français partout au
pays.
Philippe Vincent Foisy vous
serait avec Justin Trudeau. Je
serai avec vous. Il s'envole
vers la Colombie Britannique dès
le début de cette campagne.
- Oui, en début d'après-midi,
après après son point de presse.
Il vient à l'aéroport pour
s'envoler vers Vancouver. Vous
l'entendez autour de moi, je
suis sur le tarmac ou l'avion de
Justin Trudeau avec les couleurs
libérales sont bien en vue. On
est prêt ici à s'envoler plus
tard aujourd'hui. La Colombie
Britannique est l'une des
provinces où beaucoup de sièges
seront enjeux et les verts ont
un potentiel de gain. Justin
Trudeau veut marquer le coup et
commencer là pour montrer que
les libéraux ont encore un
message environnemental. Sa
stratégie va être démontrée que
les libéraux sont là pour offrir
quelque chose de nouveau dès le
début de la campagne. On va voir
Justin Trudeau dans les premiers
jours essayer d'aller dans
chaque province canadienne. On
devrait le voir vendredi au
Québec notamment. Et il va faire
plusieurs annonces dans les
premières semaines pour montrer
qu'on n'est pas là uniquement
pour défendre le bilan. Ça peut
être compliqué. Les
gouvernements ne sont pas réélus
en défendant un bilan mais en
amenant de nouvelles promesses.
Chez les libéraux on n'en est
bien conscient. On va aller de
l'avant avec de nouvelles
mesures. En environnement, la
fiscalité, pour le contrôle des
armes à feu. On va avoir
plusieurs annonces dans les
premières semaines du côté du
Parti libéral pour montrer
qu'ils sont là pour après
quelque chose de nouveau.
Vancouver ce soir. Il y aura un
événement partisan. Et ensuite
on va voir Justin Trudeau sur le
terrain dans plusieurs
circonscriptions sillonnait le
Canada. Les libéraux disent
qu'ils ne prennent aucune
province pour acquis et qu'ils
ne vont pas en négliger. Par
exemple en Alberta, il pense
pouvoir garder certains sièges.
Même dans des régions où en ce
moment les sondages ne sont pas
favorables.
- On va revoir les données de la
dissolution. C'est pas
compliqué, les libéraux ne
peuvent pas se permettre de
perdre plus que 12 ou 13
circonscriptions pour ne pas
baisser sous le seuil de la
majorité.
177, alors que les conservateurs
doivent aller chercher 70
circonscriptions. C'est ce jeu.
Les libéraux veulent garder leur
acquis et les conservateurs
doivent faire des gains
importants. Tour de table là-
dessus. Officielement dit qu'on
va aller partout mais dans les
faits, on va miser sur des
endroits bien particuliers.
- Au début on va aller partout
mais plus la campagne va avancer
plus on va cibler des
circonscriptions. Les sondages
se font tous les jours et ils
savent où se font les luttes.
Particulièrement dans une
campagne d'une quarantaine de
jours. Quand on a plus de temps,
on peut aller partout au pays.
Quand une campagne va rondement,
elle fait de circonscriptions
par jour. Faites le calcul on ne
peut pas visiter les 338
circonscriptions. On se
concentre.
- Les analyses disent que les
gouvernements se choisissent en
Ontario. Et la majorité se
détermine au Québec ou non.
C'est encore vrai cette année?
- Le Québec et la Colombie
Britannique et l'Ontario. Mais
le Québec est important parce
qu'on voit la dégringolade du
NPD. Qui ça va profiter? Est-ce
que le blog va reprendre les
votes? Est-ce que les partie de
Maxime Bernier va gruger des
votes conservateurs? En
Atlantique les conservateurs
vont prendre des sièges
probablement.
- En Atlantique les libéraux ont
tous les sièges. Il risque d'en
perdre quelques-uns.
- Je ne pense pas que ça sera un
ouragan conservateur mais une
vague. À part ça, le reste du
pays, on ne peut rien prédire à
ce stade.
- Les 16 qui sont maintenant 14
circonscriptions du NPD au
Québec, les autres parties comme
des vautours tournent autour.
- C'est un buffet ouvert.
Évidemment c'est là qu'on voit à
quel point les chefs content. On
n'a pas besoin de rappeler le
succès de Jack Layton au Québec.
Thomas 1000 car avait réussi à
sauver les meubles. Et Jagmeet
Singh pour l'instant ça ne passe
pas. On voit dans sa publicité
où il enlève son turban et fait
de la boxe. Il se montre
sensible à l'identité
québécoise. Il veut se battre au
Québec, mais la question que
tout le monde pose avec raison,
c'est est-ce que ce n'est pas
trop tard pour s'occuper du
Québec. L'importance du Québec
on la sentit dans tout le
dossier de la laïcité. Le projet
de loi 21, les partis fédéraux
marchent sur des oeufs. Monsieur
Trudeau a dit qu'il était contre
au début mais il s'était
maintenant. Il ne remet pas en
question.
- Un député libéral a dit que le
gouvernement fédéral pourrait
aider des contestations
judiciaires. Et on sent le
malaise. Ce sera une des
questions pour Monsieur Trudeau.
- Il sera-t-elle née dans les
débats là-dessus parce qu'il y
aura un lendemain à cette
élection. Va-t-il changer de
discours à ce moment-là? Pour le
moment on voit que tous les
chefs sont vraiment très
sensibles à cette question parce
que la loi 21 est très populaire
dans l'électorat francophone au
Québec. On n'ose pas rien dire
et on voit dans les médias
canadiens anglais dans la
gazette, il y a des
commentateurs qui sont en furie.
Il demandait dire quelque chose.
On peut imaginer si c'était
Pierre Elliott Trudeau, il se
serait exprimé plus durement.
Mais là, on bichonne Québec. On
ne veut pas vraiment éveiller
des vieux démons sur la question
de l'identité et de la laïcité.
- On ne veut pas parler de ça.
Il y aura un réflexe de sauter
dans l'arène.
- Monsieur Trudeau ne va pas au
départ de McClain cette semaine.
Je pense pas qu'ils vont laisser
passer le projet de loi 21. Il y
a deux processeurs qui ne sont
pas engagés au Québec jusqu'à
maintenant parce qu'elle refuse
de ne pas porter leurs signes
religieux, ça fait les
manchettes partout. Monsieur
Trudeau aimerait bien ne pas en
parler parce que c'est important
pour lui le Québec pour sa
réélection.
- Louis, vous êtes à Ottawa et
vous vous rendez à Trois-
Rivières avec Andrew Sheer.
- Il veut clairement envoyer un
message. Il commence à Trois-
Rivières, c'est symbolique pour
lui. Un endroit où il veut faire
des gains. Il y aura des courses
à trois ici dans la région.
Comme à Drummondville, Saint-
Hyacinthe, des circonscriptions
détenues par les NPD. Ils
envoyaient que c'est important
pour lui, qu'il a besoin du
Québec pour former le prochain
gouvernement, tout comme la
grande région de Toronto, le
deuxième arrêt de la journée. Il
y a une possibilité de gain là
aussi. Il va aller chercher des
circonscriptions libéraux dans
le coin de Mississauga. Il sait
que tout se passe dans ce coin-
là. Derrière nous ça commence à
s'activer. L'avion est sur le
tarmac est bien en évidence il y
a le slogan du Parti
conservateur. Andrew Sheer veut
tenter de faire la question du
coût de la vie l'élément central
de cette élection. Il a
plusieurs défis devant lui.
C'est sa première campagne comme
chef fédéral. Il est peut-être
moins expérimenté que peut
l'être Justin Trudeau en
campagne et en débat. Est-ce que
son français sur un problème? On
verra bien. Il y a un point de
presse prévue vers neuf heures
30. Il commentera sûrement les
derniers développements
concernant l'affaire SNC-
Lavalin, la GRC qui n'aurait pas
eu accès à tous les documents
étaient moins qu'elle soit à
cause de la confidentialité du
cabinet. On voit qu'il veut
saisir l'occasion.
- Il va vouloir rappeler cette
affaire à chaque fois qu'il aura
un micro devant lui. On dit que
c'est sa première campagne
électorale comme chef, mais
c'est un vieux député. Il est là
depuis 2004. Il a été le plus
jeune président de la chambre
des communes. Il fait parti des
meubles à Ottawa mais il était
plus discret avant de devenir
chef. Merci beaucoup.
- Il a certainement un flair
politique mais l'expérience sur
le terrain, les anses pour
rencontrer les gens, ce sera
intéressant d'observer ça sur le
terrain. Et on dit qu'on veut le
rapprocher des gens. On veut y
aller vraiment sur des
événements où il cognera la
porte avec les gens, des
bénévoles, des barbecues. On
verra ça.
- Merci beaucoup. Au NPD, on lui
disait, c'est une bataille pour
la survie. Ça fait dramatique
mais il y a une glissade et on
se demande jusqu'où ça va aller.
Christian Noël, vous allez
suivre les NPD. Vous êtes à
London en Ontario.
- Les députés néo démocrate de
la région des acquis ici et
Jagmeet Singh veut les protéger.
C'est en ce qu'elle passe
beaucoup de temps en Ontario
durant la campagne. Dans la
région de Toronto le NPD a été
rayé de la carte en 2015 par une
vague libérale alors qu'ils
avaient quelques députés. Dans
le 905 dans la banlieue de
Toronto on espère que la
nationalité de Jagmeet Singh lui
donne les coudées franches dans
cette région pour aller chercher
les votes dans les
circonscriptions multiethniques.
Mais le NPD mais aussi sur les
régions ouvrières comme Windsor,
Oshawa et London, là où le NPD a
généralement assez fort. Les néo
démocrate malgré les glissade
dans les sondages et les
problèmes de financement, il
compte sur le terrain profiter
de la force du NPD provincial en
Ontario qui représente la
l'opposition officielle. Ils
espèrent maintenant que cette
opposition officielle qui s'est
construite une bonne machine sur
le terrain les aidera à passer
par-dessus les obstacles
auxquels ils font face
présentement.
- On faisait référence aux
publicités sur le terrain au
Québec ou Jagmeet Singh à jouer
sur sa différence en disant : je
vous comprends, vous êtes
différent du Canada. On verra
dans quelle mesure ce message va
passer. Mais le défi est énorme,
c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire. Au Manitoba hier, on le
voit, le NPD qui est le parti de
l'alternance là-bas, les
libéraux sont inexistants, je
sais pas si ça va profiter au
NPD fédéral. Ce sera avoir.
Christian, bonne campagne à
vous.
- À vous aussi.
- Julie Marceau vous est avec le
Bloc Québécois. Vous allez
sillonner le Québec. Le Bloc
Québécois se sent ragaillardi le
chef y est allé d'un objectif de
doubler la députation de 10 à
20. On verra. On veut montrer
qu'on va vers le haut, que la
traversée du désert est
terminée.
- Absolument. Ton ami les
chicanes de famille de côté et
qu'on est réuni derrière le
chef. Dans les dernières
semaines il a même parlé de
tripler la députation. Voilà
pour les objectifs. Je me trouve
dans le local de Christiane
Gagnon à Québec. Ça démarre
tranquillement. On attend les
candidats de Québec ici. On
voulait marquer le coup devant
l'Assemblée nationale. Il peut
des cordes Québec alors on a
décidé de faire ça devant le
local. L'idée pour le Bloc
Québécois et le message qui sera
martelé : nous sommes le
véritable parti qui peut
représenter les intérêts du
Québec. Le Québec, c'est nous.
L'énergie propre, c'est nous.
C'est ce qu'on voit dans les
publicités et sur les pancartes
du Bloc Québécois. On ne se
cache pas aux parties de viser
le vote francophone
nationaliste. 10 députés
actuellement, essentiellement
sur la couronne nord et la
couronne sud de Montréal. On
vise vraiment le vote
francophone dans le 450 et dans
les régions. La campagne
officielle du Bloc Québécois va
véritablement démarrer dimanche.
Aujourd'hui, on est au local, il
y aura un discours d'Yves
François Blanchet au centre des
congrès mais dimanche c'est le
dévoilement de la plate-forme
électorale. On va dévoiler
l'autobus de la campagne du
bloc. Et d'ici là on va suivre
le chef de jour en jour pour ses
activités. Particularité, on a
décidé au bloc cette fois-ci que
plutôt que de miser
circonscriptions par
circonscription, faire campagne
sur des thèmes. On est à Québec.
Démontrer qu'on représente
l'identité québécoise et les
valeurs québécoises. À partir de
dimanche sera par thèmes et dans
des lieux liés. On va commencer
avec l'environnement. Ça sera à
suivre pour dimanche. Ici ça
démarre tranquillement et on
attend les militants au cours de
la prochaine heure.
- Ils ont fait leur carte et il
y a des circonscriptions qui
pointent. La circonscription de
Chambly, c'est celle du chef. On
va aller chercher ce que le NPD
avait au Québec.
- Vous parliez des vautours
autour des circonscriptions du
NPD. Le bloc veut absolument
aller retrouver certains des
bastions qui étaient péquistes.
Bailey Chambly où se présente le
chef, Berthier aussi, Abitibi
Témiscamingue. On va compter
aussi sur la machine péquiste
dans certaines circonscriptions.
À Matane entre autres. La
circonscription de Pascal
Bérubé.
Le PQ avait eu plus de 60 % des
voilà. Toute la machine qui se
met en branle. Il y a ça, mais
le Bloc Québécois, on verra,
mais évidemment l'idée de
maintenir les acquis où ils sont
actuellement est de faire des
gains. Est-ce que ce sera deux
ou 10? 15 de plus? C'est entre
les mains des électeurs. Le
blocs parents Lyon pour
l'instant au niveau de la
confiance des candidats.
- Dirigeant surveillé : Québec
et Ontario. Les 450 Montréal est
intéressant parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'anciennes
circonscriptions....
Il reste que cette région que la
CAQ a balayée lors des dernière
élection, ce que le bloc
aimerait, c'est que le bleu
caquiste se transforme en
bloquistes. C'est ce qui rend la
campagne intéressante Québec.
- L'ange environnemental sera un
terme incontournable n'est-ce
pas ?
- Les gens sont beaucoup plus
enclins à parler aujourd'hui.
C'est le thème qui porte
aujourd'hui dans certaines
régions.
- Ça peut diviser le vote
progressiste. Entre les NPD et
les verts et les libéraux.
- Madeleine Blais Morin bonjour
à vous. Vous êtes sur le terrain
de l'arrêt lieutenant gouverneur
général. Le thème de
l'environnement va s'imposer
milliard à d'autres sujets. Il y
aura des questions d'éthique que
M. Scheer voudra remettre à
plat.
- Et parfois on réalise que
c'est des sujets qu'on n'a pas
vu venir finalement qui sont
déterminants dans les campagnes
souvenez-vous de 2015 la
question du niqab finalement qui
avait j'étais en colère les
plans NPD. On peut regarder ce
qui se passe n'est pas la
question de la fiscalité, mais
aussi du coût de la vie pour les
consommateurs. On sent que le
parti conservateur veut que vous
en ayez plus dans vos poches,
mais le Parti libéral veut
essayer aussi d'apaiser les
craintes de la classe moyenne
quant à la façon debout clé les
fins de mois. On va voir de
quelle façon leurs politiques
vont s'arrimer à ce sujet.
L'environnement consacrerait un
enjeu. C'était ce que la
campagne de Stéphane Dion, son
fameux plan vers. Il y avait des
tourments économiques et les
citoyens et contribuables
s'étaient retournés sur des
questions d'avantages
économiques. Ces enjeux bougent
durant la campagne, ce n'est pas
stable et fixé d'avance. Les
parties ont beau faire des
plans, il faut vérifier quelle
est leur flexibilité, à quel
point ils peuvent s'adapter.
Parce que c'est aussi d'être
capae de faire face a des
enjeux rapidement.
- Merci Madeleine vous restait
là. Justin Trudeau sera la
résidence de la gouverneur
général pour demander la
dissolution de la chambre des
communes et la campagne va
commencer à ce moment. Il va
faire son premier point de
presse ensuite. On va bien
évidemment vous présenter tous
les points de presse et les
analyser. Pour vous donner une
idée où va se jouer cette
campagne électorale. Michel
avant de vous laisser aller à la
radio. Il y a d'autres
questions, l'immigration est-ce
que c'est vraiment une question
?
- Merci dernier a de ce toxique
comme il le fait avec
l'environnement. Si vous touchez
à l'immigration vous êtes dans
le cas de Maxime Bernier et cela
risque de rendre la chose
difficile. Et rendent cela
difficile pour M. Scheer d'en
faire un enjeu.
- Il y a des choses qui se
passent au pays par exemple avec
la Chine et il y a eu des
accords commerciaux qui ont été
signés qui ont un impact sur
notre vie. Est-ce que ces
questions vont émerger?
- Les enjeux internationaux ça
ne touche pas la personne
moyenne et ce n'est pas quelque
chose de déterminant. Par
exemple, ça va faire mal aux
conservateurs qui aimeraient
pouvoir jouer là-dessus par
exemple en parlant de ces
frasques en même.
- Ce qui joue du point de vue de
M. Trudeau qui est positif le
nouvel accord avec le nouvel
accord avec les États-Unis nord-
américains. Tout le monde
comprend qu'avoir à s'occuper de
notre c'est un enjeu à plein
temps pour le gouvernement et
qui s'en est tiré.
- Quand Monsieur Mulroney
félicite M. Trudeau ce qu'il
quelque chose?
- Pourrait toucher il ne peut
pas gagner : avec cette
question. En réalité, le pouvoir
canadien est assez faible dans
les grandes institutions et ce
n'est pas nous qui va décider de
l'avenir de la planète. On ne
boit être un pays du G7, je ne
suis pas certain que les gens
comprennent que le Canada n'a
pas beaucoup de poids.
- Le début du mandat de Justin
Trudeau où il était devenu un
globe-trotter tellement il se
promenait. Il était partout,
c'était une star. Il des selfie
avec ce jeune Philippine etc. Il
reste que ce souvenir est encore
là, il n'existe plus dans le
présent, Justin Trudeau n'est
plus cette rockstar. Il il y a à
cette force il a eu cette force
cela est peut-être Monsieur peut
rapporter l'histoire du costume
en Inde, mais les libéraux
peuvent rapporter des souvenirs
plus agréables sur la scène
internationale.
- Je vous libère Michel C. Auger
pour votre émission à la radio.
Merci.
- Laurence Martin à Ottawa ou il
y a vraiment une lutte à trois
pour parler de cette lutte à
trois vous est avec la chef
Elizabeth May.
- Les valeurs nous l'ont dit
cela parfois qu'ils ont autant
d'attention médiatique.
Elizabeth May qui lance sa
campagne sur l'île de Doria à
Vancouver. C'est assez
tranquille, il est six heures du
matin en Colombie-Britannique.
S'intéressant parce que c'est
hile de Vancouver, il y en a
deux qui sont détenus par les
verts, quatre par les NPD. Les
verres espèrent faire des gains
ici. Elizabeth May va passer
beaucoup de temps Colombie-
Britannique pendant sa campagne.
Elle va aller dans les provinces
d'Atlantique et au Québec où le
Québec espère faire des gains.
Madame et qui va être le 27
septembre à la marche pour le
climat. On veut rassembler
autour de l'enjeu de
l'environnement, mais le défi
pour les verts c'est de montrer
qu'il y a autre chose que la
balade forme environnementale,
on a tout un programme. On veut
se présenter comme centriste,
parce qu'on est pour le revenu
mis Ri Pom garantie, mais en
même temps on veut revenir à
l'équilibre budgétaire comme les
conservateurs. Est-ce que ce
sera des questions qui vont
polaires aux Canadiens? On est
de trouver un bus électrique
mais ce n'était pas évident et
elle va faire campagne en auto
électrique.
- La géographie du Canada fait
que l'avion est un peu
incontournable, mais elle va
acheter ce crédit carbone. Elle
est furieuse parce qu'il y a
deux débats organisés par la
commission des débats ou on
disait au gouvernement faire le
ménage, parce que la dernière
fois il n'y a pas eu de débat
anglophone. TVA organise en
parallèle leur fameux face-à-
face et ils n'ont pas invité
Elizabeth May et elle est en
colère, parce qu'elle dit qu'au
Québec elle est compétitive,
autant que le NPD ou presque.
C'est une occasion de moins pour
elle pour se faire valoir?
- Oui vous avez parlé des
sondages et vous l'avez vu
depuis le début de l'année. Au
niveau national, le Parti vert
était à 6, 7 %. C'est la
bataille pour la 3, Place face
au NPD. Si je ne peux pas
présenter mes idées comment est-
ce que je peux faire des gains
dit-elle.
- Sébastien Saint-François nous
terminons notre tournée avec
vous. Maxime Bernier fâché parce
que la commission de la pas
invité parce qu'il ne répond pas
aux trois critères, soit d'avoir
élu un débilité, d'avoir de
bonnes chances de faire élire
quelques députés, il a seulement
le troisième critère. Il va dans
sa campagne en Ontario.
- Il va répondre à la visite de
Justin Trudeau vers 13 heures
30. Monsieur Bernier a déjà
lancé sa campagne il y a plus
d'une semaine en Beauce, mais
dans les faits il va dans les
faits à Toronto. Il va être en
Ontario à de nombreuses
reprises, dans le mois de
septembre. Il est anodine hier
soir où notre Christian Noël se
trouve avec les NPD. On espère
aller chercher des va dans ce
côté-là. Il est évident faire
une visite à Bellevil il a déjà
fait des visites à Trenton.
Ensuite il va aller vers
Hamilton. Il a divisé pour
l'Ontario. On sent qu'il a une
sur l'Ontario. L'Ontario c'est
plus de 120 sièges, les grands
Toronto pèsent plus lourd que
certaines provinces dans les
maritimes. Monsieur Bernier, il
espère faire certaines percées
ici. Il y a, il est anodine, il
est revenu sur certains termes
de sa campagne et de ce que sont
partis représenter. Il veut
privatiser certains posts, il va
répéter ce thème la. Aujourd'hui
Maxime Bernier, il va souligner
le début de la campagne à
Etobicoke-Lakeshore, l'ancien
fief de Rob Ford, avec la veuve
de celui-ci. On verra ça va
donner des résultats.
- Les gens ont déchanté devant
les plans de conservateurs en
Ontario. Bonne campagne en
Ontario.Merci.
en Beauce.
- Toute la question de la
gestion de l'offre en Beauce, il
veut abolir la gestion de
l'offre. C'est ce qui lui a
coûté la chefferie. Il faut
d'abord que pour son parti
survivent et qu'il assure une
présence à la chambre des
communes. Et les majorités dans
temps ne sont pas acquis.
- Peut-être reprendre son jingle
? Ce convoi chez Maxime Bernier,
ce qu'il s'est beaucoup
discrédité dans les dernières
semaines avec des déclarations
intempestives, rétrogrades.
Qu'on soit pro environnement ou
pas c'était vraiment très
personnel. L'Ontario,
s'intéressant. Je pense que le
populisme au Canada c'est
marginal. Oui il essaie, c'est
l'ultime populiste et il essaie
de s'accrocher après la famille
Ford, mais ce n'est plus les
beaux jours de ce côté. Il n'a
pas beaucoup de choix et voyez
où il est dans les sondages, il
est dans la marge d'erreur.
- Je pense qu'époque François
Legault et roqueforts sont des
marginaux. Je connais Maxime
Bernier et je ne comprends pas
Maxime Bernier aujourd'hui. Son
revirement c'est quelque chose
qui ne parlait pas, les attaques
personnelles, les attaques ce
n'est pas l'ancien Maxime
Bernier. On avait essaie de
faire... et ce n'était pas dans
son décor avant cela esquisse un
calcul électoraliste, est-ce que
ça porté fruit ? je ne pense
pas. Les conservateurs ont perdu
des plumes, on pense qu'il ne
sait pas ce qu'il fait en
parlant de Rob Ford. Alors ça
c'est terni son image, lui se
pour les conservateurs, moins
qu'un atout pour les
conservateurs, parce qu'on
connecte les deux. Est-ce qu'on
veut cela en fédéral?
- Maxime Bernier des plus
beaucoup prise au sérieux ?
- Dans les cercles d'extrême
droite c'est là qu'il est plus
mieux vu. Ça me déçoit.
- Il actuellement, ce qui peut
faire garder et grandir 70 pour
faire griser les conservateurs
mais les 4 % qu'il est dans les
sondages actuellement c'est
probablement des gens qui
seraient restés à la maison si
Maxime Bernier n'existait pas.
- Il allait reconduire ses
enfants à l'école, donc la vie
de famille qu'il veut projeter.
- C'est intéressant comme image,
l'image qu'il essaie de projeter
où il est très relaxe. Il avec
ses enfants, donc je suis le
premier ministre, je suis en
contrôle, je suis un homme de
famille, je ne suis pas stressé.
C'est vraiment une image très
frappante et ce qu'il essaie de
communiquer à mon avis ce qu'il
est en contrôle et cette
campagne va bien se passer pour
nous. Et aussi la présence de
Sophie Grégoire était disparue
depuis plusieurs mois. Et là on
apprend qu'elle va assumer une
présence au Québec, parce que
Sophie Grégoire c'est quelqu'un
qui a beaucoup de bagout, elle
est très affable. La présence de
Sophie Grégoire n'est pas un
hasard ce matin.
- On veut montrer l'unité, le
calme.
- Anne Faucher avait sorti une
vidéo avec ses enfants qui
faisaient le déjeuner. Les
conservateurs c'est très
important cette image, les
libéraux tente de jouer cette
image est de montrer que c'est
un père de famille et qu'il veut
faire des choses avec ses
enfants.
- Dans quel esprit sont les
stratèges libéraux actuellement.
?
- On est beaucoup plus confiant
en ce moment et vous voyez dans
les vidéos qu'on a déterrées
chez les libéraux. On a sorti
beaucoup de vidéos sur Andrew
Scheer, on sent que la banque
électorale des libéraux est très
actif en ce moment. On les sent
plus d'attaque, il devrait aller
chercher un deuxième mandat et
si si il perde ce sera de leur
faute. Dans certaines régions il
va avoir des côtes à monter.
- On ne voudra pas décevoir
François Legault qui flotte sur
un nuage ici au Québec.
Sébastien Bovet vous êtes avec
nous. Par exemple sur la
laïcité, même si Justin Trudeau
voudrait dire qu'il est contre
cela. On a bien entendu de cela,
parce qu'on ne veut pas froisser
l'électorat québécois.
- Entre leur position dans le
reste du Canada. Laïcité ça ne
fera peut-être pas parti dans la
liste de demande de François
Legault. Monsieur Legault va
faire sa demande la semaine
prochaine parce que dans le
calendrier il y a le
déclenchement aujourd'hui et la
CAQ est encore plus demain. Dans
sa liste de demandes il n'y aura
pas la laïcité. Mais la laïcité
va s'inviter dans le débat. Les
chefs devront prendre position
sur ce sujet. J'ai Trudeau est
contre la loi québécoise, M.
Scheer dit que c'est la
prérogative du gouvernement du
Québec de légiférer dans ce
domaine. De même que l'arrêté
pris dans ce débat sur la
laïcité. Alors ça peut faire
perdre des points sur les chefs
fédéraux. Rappelons les forces
en présence au Québec.
- On a l'impression que c'est
les circonscriptions du NPD qui
sont en jeu en ce moment. Les
conservateurs misent sur le
sentiment pour être
l'alternative au gouvernement
Trudeau. Ici au Québec les
députés ne prendront pas
position. Ce qui veut pas dire
que Monsieur Legault n'aura pas
des demandes. Il pourrait y
avoir par exemple le financement
des projets d'infrastructures,
le troisième lien à Québec,
Monsieur Legault a fait planer
l'ombre du péage sur le
troisième lien. On s'est
toujours pas ça va coûter
combien le troisième lien. Les
Les estimés sont entre 4 et 10
mill. Andrew Scheer monde les
...
il y a des questions vis-à-vis
fédérale pour pouvoir avoir le
pouvoir d'imposer le test des
valeurs aux nouveaux arrivants.
Il a besoin du feu vert
d'Ottawa. Justin Trudeau même
pas comment M. Trudeau fêtent
les choses. Andrew Scheer dit
que c'est la prérogative du
gouvernement du Québec. Il ouvre
pour ouvrer plus de pouvoirs au
Québec. Donc l'immigration
pourrait se retrouver sur la
liste d'épicerie de François
Legault.
- On vous retrouve Sébastien aux
mordus de politique. Michel
Les libéraux ont rasé, ont
remporté toutes les
circonscriptions des maritimes
et de l'Atlantique. 32/32.
On estime qu'il y aura des
pertes chez vous.
- C'était un score parfait.
C'était du jamais vu.
Alors évidemment, ça été pour
eux une grande victoire. Mais
cela a changé 2015 quand même.ÀA
l'époque, les libéraux
semblaient la solution pour
défaire le gouvernement de
Stephen Harper.
On avait pas aimé
la façon dont le gouvernement
avait géré l'assurance emploi.
Justin Trudeau avait dit à
l'époque que l'on ne prendra pas
l'Atlantique pour acquis.
Il avait nommé deux ministres,
l'une à la santé et l'autre aux
affaires intergouvernementales.
Il est venu lors des
inondations. Il était hier à
Halifax pour le lendemain
de l'ouragan.
Il y avait à l'époque aussi,
vous vous en rappelez, quatre
gouvernements provinciaux. Il y
avait quatre gouvernements
provinciaux qui étaient
libéraux. C'était rouge partout
en Atlantique en 2015.
Les libéraux ont été défaits.
Les libéraux de Brian Gallant
étaient défaits par les
conservateurs. À l'île du Prince
Édouard, les libéraux ont été
défaits. Les verres sont arrivés
deuxièmes. Les libéraux ont
terminé troisième.
Il y a un vent de changement. Il
y a aussi des dossiers qui ont
choqué un peu les gens de
l'Atlantique. Le pipeline
énergie est est tombé à l'eau.
Et aussi le dossier de la
tarification du carbone. Le
premier ministre milite contre
la tarification du carbone. Il
convainc des électeurs. On verra
si tout cela va faire du tort
aux libéraux du Justin Trudeau.
- Les verres en opposition
officielle s'accrochent
à ça. On peut avoir une présence
significative dans le jeu
politique dans les provinces au
Canada. Bonne campagne à vous.
Je vous montre une carte
du Canada. Il y a eu, disons que
M. Trudeau, ses amis rouges, il
n'y en a plus beaucoup.
Les conservateurs ont repris le
pouvoir au Manitoba.
Regardez la carte des provinces.
Tasha, il n'y a plus beaucoup de
gouvernements libéraux ami
indéfectibles de Justin Trudeau.
- Doug Ford en Ontario fait
campagne contre lui dans un
certain sens.
En Colombie-Britannique, c'est
le NPD.
La lutte est à trois.
Ça peut profiter aux libéraux
dans un certain sens. Je ne suis
pas convaincu qu'il est aussi
misérable qu'il était. En
campagne en 2015, il fait des
promesses, d'être le grand
rassembleur.
Je ne sais pas la dernière
réunion à laquelle M. Trudeau a
assisté. Ça fait un an je pense.
- Il avait beaucoup critiqué M.
Harper à l'époque. Il disait
qu'il snobait le premier
ministre. Il avait redonné quand
même de l'autonomie et des
pouvoirs aux provinces.
- Il y a une certaine
alternance.
- Que voulez-vous ajouter?
- La dernière conférence des
premiers ministres était en
décembre. Ça fait moins d'un an.
En politique, on est aussi bon
que l'adversaire que l'on
affronte. Il est capable de se
promener en faisant campagne
contre Andrew Scheer. Il ne fera
pas campagne contre François
Legault. Ailleurs, on est
capable de dire aux insatisfaits
qu'ils ont une alternative au
fédéral. Je suis d'accord, ce
n'est pas aussi misérable que la
carte peut le laisser penser.
- Il apparaît plus clairement
avec ses propositions à lui.
- C'est clair que son
positionnement face à ce bleu
omniprésent, ça va être le
progressisme. Le retour de
Gerald Butts aussi dans son
entourage. C'est un conseiller
assez progressiste. Je parlais
au début de l'émission de la
vision collective de M. Trudeau.
C'est un peu ça aussi. Je pense
que ça va se décliner comme ça
pour les libéraux pendant la
campagne.
- Le seul chemin de la victoire
pour M. Trudeau et de coaliser
la gauche. Être le seul rempart
contre le gouvernement
conservateur. S'il réussit cela,
il va gagner l'élection. Le bloc
conservateur...
- voici des images en direct.
Andrew Sheer va prendre son
avion. C'est le premier voyage à
la campagne. On l'écoute.
- Donc l'entrave à la justice du
bureau du premier ministre,
Justin Trudeau fait tout ce
qu'il peut afin de bloquer cette
enquête. Moi, je fais appel à M.
Trudeau. Renoncé à tous les
privilèges pour que les
individus puissent témoigner
devant la GRC.
Premièrement, la GRC fait
enquête sur une possible entrave
à la justice. Deux, Justin
Trudeau va tout faire pour le
bloquer. Alors je lui demande de
se lever le privilège dès
maintenant. Merci.
- Bonjour. Radio-Canada. Est-ce
que l'article du globe and mail
a changé votre stratégie.
- Nous parlons canadiens. Nous
leur disons à quel point M.
Trudeau a induit en erreur le
Canadien. Il a menti carrément
en disant des choses qu'il
savait fausse. Et nous, notre
argumentaire, c'est qu'il a
perdu l'autorité morale de
gouverner. Nous allons présenter
notre vision du pays pour mettre
plus d'argent entre les mains du
Canadiens.
On ne peut pas faire confiance à
Justin Trudeau. Il dit n'importe
quoi pour camoufler ses
scandales. Il fera n'importe
quoi pour se faire réélire. Les
Canadiens ne peuvent plus le
croire.
- On l'a vu, ça n'a pas fait
bouger l'aiguille pour M.
Trudeau. Qu'est-ce qui vous fait
croire que ça peut être
différent aujourd'hui.
- Ce scandale, ce n'est pas une
question de l'impact sur les
sondages. C'est une question de
l'intégrité. Est-ce que Justin
Trudeau à l'autorité morale
continue de gouverner. Pendant
les prochaines semaines, les
prochains jours, je vais
démontrer aux Canadiens les
raisons pour lesquelles Justin
Trudeau a perdu l'autorité
morale de continuer de
gouverner. Notre gouvernement va
vivre selon ses moyens d'ajouter
plus d'argent dans les poches
des Canadiens lorsqu'il peut
améliorer le quotidien. C'est
notre message. Je suis sûr que
notre message va raisonner avec
les Canadiens et que les
Canadiens veulent un
gouvernement qui respecte les
lois de l'éthique.
- Est-ce que la GRC doit rester
de côté.
- Aujourd'hui je fais un appel
pour donner le privilège lorsque
les individus témoignent, pour
donner leur évidence à la GRC.
- Pensez-vous que le premier
ministre dit la vérité quand il
dit qu'il n'avait aucun lien
avec le renoncement à ce secret
du conseil des ministres?
- Non, je pense qu'il a menti
aux Canadiens. Le pouvoir de
renoncer à la confidentialité du
cabinet et le pouvoir de lever
le privilège et entre les mains
du premier ministre. Il a le
pouvoir de le faire. Il devrait
agir aujourd'hui même.
- Vous vous rendez à Québec.
Est-ce que vous allez parler du
projet de loi 21?
- J'ai été clair là-dessus.
Notre parti ne pourrait jamais
envisager cela au niveau
fédéral. Nous allons toujours
défendre les droits des
Canadiens. Et la liberté
d'expression religieuse.
- Bonjour M. Sheer. Le
commissaire à l'éthique n'a pas
vraiment influencé l'opinion
politique de l'électorat. Qu'en
pensez-vous.
- Ce n'est pas une question de
sondage. Il faut démontrer aux
Canadiens que M. Trudeau a
perdus l'autorité morale de
gouverner.
C'est très important que M.
Trudeau prenne des
responsabilités personnelles et
qu'il lève le privilège. Il a le
pouvoir de le faire. Il va
mentir aujourd'hui là-dessus. Il
va continuer de mentir. Il a
regardé les Canadiens droits
dans les yeux. Il a dit que
c'était faux. Il a dit que Mme
Sandrine Bordes n'a jamais
exprimé ses préoccupations...
Mme Jody Wilson-Raybould.
Dès le début du scandale, il a
été incapable face aux
Canadiens. Tour après tour, il
s'est fait prendre la main dans
le sac des mensonges. Alors son
refus de renoncer au secret, ça
veut dire qu'il cache quelque
chose de pire. C'est n'avait
rien à cacher, il laisserait la
GRC faire son travail.
- Justin Trudeau va mentir
aujourd'hui.
Alors la seule raison pour
laquelle Justin Trudeau va
continuer de refuser de lever le
privilège, c'est parce qu'il a-
quelque chose à cacher de plus
graves.
Merci.
- Andrew Sheer, premier point de
presse de cette campagne
électorale. Justin Trudeau dit
il a perdu l'autorité morale
pour gouverner. Il s'accroche à
cette nouvelle du Globe and Mail
ce matin.
Des ministres sont liés au
secret, ils ne peuvent pas
collaborer pleinement à
l'enquête. Il ne pourrait pas
collaborer pleinement l'enquête
de la GRC. Donc il met l'accent
bien sûr sur cela. On aura
l'occasion de le décortiquer.
Il revient avec son leitmotif.
Il ne veut pas oublier le grand-
angle. Mais cette question de
confiance, d'éthique, va être au
centre de sa campagne. D'autant
plus que le journal lui donne
des munitions ce matin.
- C'est un beau cadeau qu'il
fait à M. Sheer ce matin. On
verra si ça va apporter des
dividendes pour lui.
L'affaire SNC Lavalin, c'est le
discours d'Andrew Scheer. Justin
Trudeau serait corrompu.
Il le traite ouvertement de
menteur.
Il a dit qu'il a menti. Il le
traite de menteur.
Il n'a pas dit qu'il a induit la
population en erreur.
C'est le langage codé.
Donc, c'est d'essayer de ramener
cette image Parti libéral, du
scandale des commandites.
M. Sheer mais toujours le mot au
pluriel aussi. Il parle de
scandale au pluriel.
Ce que je trouve bizarre dans
son discours, c'est quand il dit
: nous, l'alternative, il parle
de remettre de l'argent dans les
poches des Canadiens. Quand
Stephen Harper était allé
fortement sur la question de
l'éthique, avec les libéraux
sous Jean Chrétien et Paul
Martin, il avait du matériel à
mettre sur la table. Nous, on
sera plus blanc que blanc. Voici
comment nous allons faire.
- Il y avait des faits
indéniables.
- Ce qui se démarque, c'est
qu'il y avait de l'argent.
L'argent a été mis dans les
poches des libéraux.
- Personne n'a trouvé cela.
Personne n'a prouvé ça.
Ce scandale, c'est une chicane
entre les ministres du cabinet
et une enfreinte à la loi.
Les Canadiens ne comprennent pas
toutes les nuances.
C'est pour ça que c'est plus
difficile pour M. Sheer que de
faire de la matière avec la
commission gommerait. Les gens
comprenaient.
- Des rapports à la
photocopieuse. 300 000 $ le
rapport. C'était clair.
Le dossier SNC-Lavalin est plus
compliqué.
- Mais quand on traite un
premier ministre de menteur, il
faut aussi offrir une
alternative sur ce plan.
Pourquoi j'aurais moi,
l'autorité morale. Voici ce que
moi je ferai.
Jusqu'à maintenant, sa réponse,
il parle d'argent dans les
poches des électeurs.
- Est-ce qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de village sur SNC-
Lavalin à faire.
- C'est le seul premier ministre
de l'histoire à avoir enfreint
la loi deux fois sur les
conflits d'intérêts. Les
conservateurs ont le beau jeu.
Le rapport du commissaire Dion
est arrivé et les libéraux sont
montés dans les sondages. On
blâme Justin Trudeau on trouve
qu'il a bien agi pour l'intérêt
québécois. Mais les tranchées
sont profondes. Il ne reste plus
beaucoup de gens qui se
promènent entre ces deux
opinions. C'était un rapport
sévère. Ça n'a pas fait bouger
l'aiguille.
- Ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on a parlé tantôt. À quel
point les chefs fédéraux
voudront se porter sur la loi
québécoise. Ici Andrew Scheer
avait pu disparaître Hong Kong
pose la question sur les droits
de des personnes.
- On l'a dit tantôt que ce n'est
pas une question que les gens
veulent toucher, celle des la
laïcité. Les conservateurs ont
une tradition nationaliste
envers le Québec. Monsieur
Harper avait reconnu
l'autodétermination du Québec
dans son premier mandat je
crois. C'est quelque chose que
parti de l'ADN des
conservateurs, alors M. Scheer
ne va pas prendre position sur
le projet de loi 21. Ce n'est
pas son avantage.
- Bonjour Gérald. On veut qu'il
donne ses lumières, parce qu'on
veut parler de fiscalité et
d'impôt. Est-ce que l'économie
canadienne va mieux aujourd'hui
qu'il y a quatre ans?
- L'économie canadienne est en
croissance pendant quatre ans.
Il y a une récession technique
en 2015, parce qu'il y avait des
mois de régression. Maintenant,
depuis quatre ans on encastre
croissance économique. 2016 et
2017 ont été des bonnes années.
Le problème au Canada séquelle
l'Alberta n'arrive pas à se
relever des sites de prise
pétrole. L'Alberta est affaiblie
par cela s'approche une
récession, tente de remonter la
pente. La croissance c'est en
Ontario et au Québec. Tout est
créé au Québec et en Ontario, en
grande partie. De ce côté-ci du
Canada l'économie va bien et
probablement que M. Trudeau peut
en tirer profit. Mais en Alberta
il y a une vraie tension, parce
que le prix du site pétrole
demeure faible.
- Il y a une véritable coupure
entre l'ouest du Canada il est
qui comprend l'Ontario et le
Québec.
- Nous manquons d'emploi au
Canada, alors ça ralentit
l'économie. M. Trudeau s'en va
dans un sens un bon moment, sur
le plan économique, parce que la
récession est possible en 2020
ou 2021. La main-d'oeuvre
ralentit l'économie et c'est
certain que le prochain premier
ministre que ce soit M. Trudeau
une autre personne. Il aura à
gérer une contraction, un
ralentissement économique. Ce
sera dans son mandat.
- M. Scheer promet de revenir à
l'équilibre budgétaire. Ça prend
plus de temps ce qu'il dit peut-
être cinq ans. Il ne veut pas
qu'on croit qu'il y ait
décompression comme en Ontario.
Est-ce que la question du défi
est une question qui angoisse
les gens? Ou bien au Canada
puisque ce n'est pas majeur?
- Je crois pas que ça angoisse
une partie de la population, la
majorité des gens par contre.
Deuxièmement les déficits ne
sont pas importants, la dette
n'est pas important par rapport
à l'économie et les Canada à des
meilleures stations financières
sur la scène internationale.
Cela disparaît quand même 70
milliards de déficits, et si on
dit récession ont dit dépenses
publiques supplémentaires, donc
plus grosses dettes. Il aura
probablement une situation
économique si les premiers
ministres, plus difficiles et du
côté de M. Trudeau, il est
difficile de remettre les
déficits zéro. Ce qu'il ne
promet plus. La question
budgétaire elle est complexe,
elle n'est pas dramatique, mais
elle peut être préoccupante si
le gouvernement par le contrôle
des dépenses et n'arrive plus à
revenir à l'équilibre.
- M. Scheer répète que M.
Trudeau est trop dépensier. Est-
ce que c'est porteur ce thème?
- Hier le global mail... a dit
que ça focalisant rembourse leur
économie au lieu de dépenser.
Début comme l'Alberta souffre
plus. Il y a au Canada un
malaise là-dessus au Canada.
Monsieur essaie de jouer là-
dessus.
- Monsieur Sandra à Trois-
Rivières pour faire campagne.
Trois-Rivières ou l'ancien maire
de Trois-Rivières se porte comme
candidat conservateur.
- Il y a une clientèle au Canada
qui se soucie de la situation
économique. Je pense que
Monsieur Trudeau n'a rien promis
à sur cela et il a été gagnant
sans promettre, en promettant de
faire des déficits. L'angoisse
est moindre dans la population.
- Aux États-Unis il y a 1000
milliards de déficits. Si la
petite bière cela.
- Comme je vous disais au Canada
c'est plus minime, c'est pas
très important par amorale
économie. La croissance
économique, vous êtes capable de
revenir à la équilibre. Ça va
bien dans l'économie, et les
défis difficiles n'ont pas
baissé.
- Il réussit à faire reculer la
pauvreté chez les enfants, est-
ce que c'est significatif. Est-
ce que les transferts d'Ottawa
ont changé la vie des gens au
Canada?
- Le point le plus important de
ce mandat c'est la location
canadienne pour enfants qui a
été véritablement bonifié et qui
a vraiment changé les choses
pour beaucoup de familles. C'est
une remise fiscale on est venu
bonifier ce qui existait déjà et
même qu'en cours de mandat, on
ne décidait de l'indexer à
l'inflation. La location
canadienne pour enfants est un
retour important pour les
familles. Il y a eu la baisse
d'impôt au début du mandat et
j'ai eu la hausse de l'impôt sur
les plus fortunés. Sur le plan
fiscal il y a un travail qui a
été fait. Est-ce qu'on peut
aller plus loin?. Qui dit baisse
d'impôts, dit déficits
supplémentaires.
- Je pense qu'il faut s'attendre
que Justin Trudeau fasse la
démonstration que pendant la
campagne, il y a beaucoup de
Kelly Dick sont inquiets
personnellement, mais il a
contribué à améliorer le sort de
la classe moyenne. En 2015
Justin Trudeau en 2015 avait
travaillé fort pour rejoindre
cette clientèle. En même temps
sur les questions difficiles, en
2015, sur le plan idéologique
Trudeau a fait faire un virage
majeur à la population qui était
conditionnée depuis 20 ans par
plein de politiciens et
d'analystes que le déficit
c'était le diable en personne.
Ça devenait un dogme. On ne
pouvait pas vice comme pays
comme cela. Justin Trudeau a
réussi à renverser cela et le
Québec qui a subi l'austérité
sous Monsieur Couillard a
beaucoup souffert de cela et je
pense que cela a marqué les
perceptions populaires que c'est
correct il est déficit quand
c'est nécessaire. Au-delà du
détail, peut-être l'aspect
abstrait pour les gens, ce n'est
plus un péché mortel.
- Ce que vous dîtes est très
important parce que la dernière
fois, savait placer Monsieur
Michael dans une de situation
parce que ça plaçait les NPD
dans une situation particulière.
Ça paraît qu'il est libéraux ont
fait et ça a donné des
résultats.
- M. Scheer se donne de la marge
de manoeuvre et ses dires commet
ne comprit que a dit, 20
milliards on est autour du zéro.
On est en bas du 1 % par rapport
au PIB.
- C'est la différence entre le
coq zéro et le croquis diète.
C'est très léger.
- On vous suit Gérald toute la
journée. On attend M. Trudeau à
rideau Hall. Il va faire une
visite de courtoisie à Madame
Payette. Le gouverneur général
va accepter sa demande de
dissoudre le parlement fédéral
élection Madeleine va commencer
tout de suite une fois qu'il
sera sorti. M. Scheer, parce que
les traditions se modifient, on
attend d'habitude que le premier
ministre fasse son allocution, a
déjà fait son point de presse.
Il y aura des questions je crois
envers M. Trudeau.
- On s'attendait questions
posées à Justin Trudeau. On va
se lancer dans une campagne qui
est relativement courte si on la
compare à celle de 2015 qui
avaient duré 78 jours. Là on est
au jour un qui vont durer 40.
Justin Trudeau doit défendre son
bilan. Tout à l'heure on parlait
de la question du déficit et
j'imagine que les libéraux vont
vouloir encore frapper
l'imaginaire avec leur promesse.
Ils vont aussi de courtiser
l'électorat canadien dans
certains comtés très précis
qu'il vise pour se maintenir au
pouvoir et il le souhaite
obtenir un autre mandat. Le
deuxième pour Justin Trudeau.
Vous parlez d'Andrew Scheer
évidemment il a tenu un point de
presse parce qu'il voulait
parler de l'affaire SNC-Lavalin
ce matin. Ce n'était pas prévu
au départ, mais quand il a vu la
du Globe and Mail, il a changé
de ce plan. J'entendais Josée
Legault qui se rapporte à son
plan de campagne, cette question
d'avoir plus de l'argent dans
nos poches. L'hiver dernier
Andrew Scheer avait beaucoup
critiqué le gouvernement, mais
c'était campé dans son rôle
d'opposition en faisant cela. On
ne l'avait pas beaucoup vu comme
un futur premier ministre et les
stratèges conservateurs l'ont
reconnu que ce couteau à double
tranchant. Il devait proposer
des choses aux Canadiens et
montrer qu'il était un premier
ministre en attente. J'ai vu le
point de presse de M. Scheer et
j'ai vu qu'il voulait rappeler
aux Canadiens son plan de
campagne.
C'est un peu la façon dont j'ai
vu le point de presse deux
Andrew Sheer tout à l'heure et
j'imagine que Justin Trudeau
sera questionné sur les
questions de SNC-Lavalin.
Le rapport a été déposé au mois
d'août. On sait que pendant les
campagnes électorales les
citoyens sont plus à l'écoute
alors on va voir le
retentissement aujourd'hui.
- Il y a le plan d'un côté, la
réalité de l'autre. Par exemple,
on vient d'avoir une note,
Andrew Sheer s'envole vers
Trois-Rivières. Il part d'Ottawa
mais son avion devra atterrir à
Québec parce qu'il y a des
conditions météo particulières à
Trois-Rivières. Il faut
s'ajuster. Chaque jour on doit
s'ajuster à ce que l'adversaire
dit. On rappelle aussi... ce
serait intéressant de voir
Monsieur Trudeau va prendre le
taureau par les cornes et parler
de SNC-Lavalin pour fermer le
débat et se justifier. Peut-être
voudra-t-il passer ça sous
silence. Les journalistes vont
le lui rappeler.
- Il avait commencé à être plus
offensif au mois d'août. Il
était moins sur la défensive. Il
a rappelé pourquoi on l'avait
fait. Ils divergeaient d'opinion
avec la commissaire à l'éthique.
Je pense qu'il va rappeler les
mêmes phrases au cours des
prochains mois. Est-ce que ça
s'est passé comme on voulait?
Est-ce qu'on regrette ce qu'on a
fait? Non. Il pensait aux
emplois. Libre aux Canadiens de
le croire ou non mais c'est la
ligne qu'il va suivre pour les
prochaines semaines.
- Dans la mesure où l'affaire
SNC-Lavalin a polarisé l'opinion
et que les camps sont définis,
c'est sûr qu'il va continuer sur
cette ligne là. Il faut qu'il
insiste beaucoup sur les
emplois. Et des emplois
canadiens pas juste québécois.
Il y en à l'extérieur du Québec,
il y en a plus à l'extérieur
qu'au Québec.
- Il a reconnu les pertes face à
ce dossier passé réglé. Il faut
miser sur les gens qui sont
plutôt d'accord avec l'attitude
qu'il avait. Ça le montre comme
batailleur aussi ce qu'on avait
peut-être perdu un peu.
- La question de moralité que
Andrew Sheer soulève, c'est que
ça incitait les libéraux à
sortir des vidéos de lui qui
contredise ses propos actuels.
Alors ce qu'on voit, c'est qu'il
y a une campagne morale contre
Andrew Sheer en demandant que
Monsieur Trudeau soit le chef
moral, en lui disant qu'on ne
peut pas avoir confiance, les
libéraux se sortent des vidéos,
des députés libéraux sortent des
vidéos sur Andrew Sheer, sur ses
propos qu'il a déjà tenus
auparavant. Ils font la bataille
salle contre Andrew Sheer. C'est
le fait détraquer un peu de son
message.
- La question que les ans se
sont peut-être posés dans cette
histoire de SNC-Lavalin, c'est
ce que Monsieur Trudeau avait le
ressort nécessaire. Est-ce que
ses qualités de leader avaient
disparu si tant est qu'il en
avait. Les gens se demandaient
s'ils pouvaient faire face à
l'adversité, donner le ton et
aller se battre? Le doute
s'était installé. C'est ça son
défi.
- Ce qui lui a fait perdre des
plumes dans les sondages,
c'était pas l'affaire comme
telle mais son manque de
leadership. Il était
continuellement à côté de ses
pompes. On s'en souvient. On ne
croyait pas ce qu'on voyait à
quel point il était hésitant et
changer de direction. Il a pris
du tonus. Il a trouvé sa ligne
sur SNC-Lavalin et c'était très
important ça. Quand on est
premier ministre, on veut
deuxième mandat, la question du
leadership est importante. La
compétence.
- Cette impression qu'il
changeait les histoires à tous
les jours il ne savait pas quel
message envoyé. C'était la
compétence surtout. Pour les
conservateurs ce serait plus
d'insister là-dessus peut-être
qu'il serait intéressant dans
cette campagne. Que sur les
détails. Parce que les gens ne
comprennent pas malheureusement.
- Voilà Monsieur Trudeau et son
épouse qui avance. Il nous a
rassuré, il a remis son veston
et elle s'est changée.
- On va voir s'il part en
passant.
(cliquetis appareils photo)
Sophie Grégoire va faire
campagne avec Justin Trudeau
mais aussi séparément. Au Québec
surtout mais aussi au Canada.
On sait que Sophie Grégoire a
une audience. Il y a beaucoup de
femmes et de gens aussi qu'il
aime beaucoup. 60 campagnes
électorales, tous les atouts
vont être joués dans cette
campagne.
- Pour jouer aussi sur l'image
féministe du premier ministre.
Elle fait du travail de
bénévolat sur le sujet. Elle
peut aider son premier ministre
qui a souffert un peu sur son
côté féministe à cause de SNC-
Lavalin.
- On ne peut pas dire de façon
générale que Justin Trudeau
n'est pas sensible à la cause
des femmes.
- Mais on pense qu'il n'a pas
bien traité certaines femmes
dans son cabinet.
- Les déclarations de deux
Andrew Sheer sur l'avortement
n'ont rien fait pour l'aider lui
non plus. C'est pour ça que la
présence de Sophie Grégoire va
consolider peut-être même
augmenter la part de l'électorat
féminin.
- Monsieur Trudeau va peut-être
parler d'avortement aussi dans
une tirade pour dire : si vous
ne voulez pas rouvrir de vieux
débats en faisant référence à
l'avortement. Il va jouer là-
dessus aussi.
- Les libéraux ont déterré
quatre vidéos sur Andrew Sheer
et ont mis ça sur Twitter et
Facebook. Ce n'est pas tant de
parler de compression et
d'éducation, d'avortement, etc.
C'est de dire que les
conservateurs ont un agenda
caché. Ils ne disent pas ce
qu'ils vont faire sur
l'avortement et les
compressions. Ça a bien marché à
l'époque de Stephen Harper
lorsque Monsieur Martin était
resté accroché au pouvoir. On
multiplie le type de vidéo sur
le passé de Andrew Sheer en
espérant de coaliser le vote
progressiste autour de Justin
Trudeau et de barrer la route
aux conservateurs. On va essayer
en espérant que ça fonctionne.
- Comment Andrew Sheer est
équipée pour faire face à ça?
- Justement il n'est pas très
bien équipé. Il est d'un
conservatisme social beaucoup
plus appuyé que Stephen Harper.
C'est un handicap aussi. C'est
peut-être une forme dans sa base
électorale mais un handicap pour
essayer d'élargir l'attente
conservatrice.
Dans la mesure où il n'est pas
capable de dire clairement
contrairement Monsieur Trudeau
qu'il est pour le droit des
femmes au libre choix, ça va
rester un handicap. Ça bouge
être de vieux discours déterré,
d'après ce qu'on entend, sa
position n'a pas tant changé.
- Ça va dans les slogans aussi
des parties. On parle de ne pas
reculer. L'ancien temps, on ne
veut pas reculer. Les mots
utilisés en anglais résonnent
très fort. Ce n'est pas par
hasard que les libéraux ont
choisi seul slogan. Et les
conservateurs ont dit : pour
vous maintenant. Ils veulent
dire qu'ils vont miser sur
l'économie. Andrew Sheer dans un
certain sens il y a une partie
de son électorat qui aimerait
retourner en arrière et dans
certains choix aussi. Le
progressisme à tout prix ce
n'est pas nécessairement la
façon de gouverner d'aller
toujours de l'avant. Il faut
regarder dans la tradition.
C'est une position progressiste
conservatrice importante.
- Il y a une partie de ses
députés qui voudraient revenir
en arrière. Il doit composer
avec les deux tendances dans son
parti.
- Sur les questions sociales
mais aussi question de la
société où la famille était très
importante, où on pouvait se
procurer un logement, toute la
question... une vision utopique
des années 50 peut-être ou plus
récemment où c'était plus
facile. À Toronto n'oubliez pas
que le coût moyen d'une maison
et plus de 1 million de dollars.
La classe moyenne dans le 950 ne
peut pas avoir de maison. Cette
vision disparaît. Cette vision
d'avant on pouvait avoir cette
belle vie. C'est quelque chose
auquel des gens s'accroche.
- C'est pas pour rien que les
conservateurs fondent campagne
là-dessus. L'économie va bien.
Les emplois sont disponibles. La
progression des salaires n'est
pas aussi marquée. Une grosse
partie de la classe moyenne
Stein. C'est difficile d'acheter
une maison dans quelques
régions, Toronto, l'Alberta.
Est-ce que je suis capable
d'élever mes enfants et accéder
à la propriété? À Montréal, le
prix des maisons bondit aussi.
On le sent aussi. Ce qu'il est
trop tôt? Est-ce Andrew Sheer
veut seulement marquer. Si on
est capable de ramener ça
individuellement chacun parce
que le grand tableau va bien,
ils ont peut-être des chances.
- Est-ce qu'on se dit que les
gens vont découvrir Andrew Sheer
pendant la campagne?
- Je pense qu'il va miser sur
les débats pour se démarquer.
Doit se montrait. Il doit
démontrer plus de charisme. Il
se positionne comme un chef
fort. Il doit donner cette
impression. C'est important pour
lui de se positionner ainsi. Je
sais pas exactement comment elle
va choisir ces moments mais je
pense que les débats seront des
occasions pour lui de pointer
Monsieur Trudeau, de marquer ses
faiblesses, lui rappeler ses
faiblesses. Andrew Sheer en
dépend il était le speaker de la
chambre des communes pendant
longtemps. On n'a pas d'image
de lui comme débatteurs.
- Les moments inscrits à votre
calendrier. 7 octobre, débats en
anglais. 10 octobre débat en
français et il y aura les face-
à-face de TVA également pour le
marché québécois. C'est tout,
Monsieur Trudeau n'en fait pas
d'autres.
- Je ne sais pas pourquoi
Monsieur Trudeau ne va pas aux
débats Toronto parce qu'il avait
bien fait.
- Si on revient Andrew Sheer,
c'est intéressant parce qu'elle
a quand même la personnalité
qu'il a. Où il se présente comme
le premier ministre en attente.
C'est vrai. Il doit donner une
image de leader fort. Mais en
même temps, la population, c'est
peut-être parce qu'elle cherche
non plus. On est à unèr plus
moderne, on veut des gens plus
émotifs. Justin Trudeau a bien
fonctionné dans ce créneau. Mais
Andrew Sheer, on ne peut pas le
refaire.
- Je me souviens des débats à
propos de Stephen Harper. Un été
on disait qu'il ne serait jamais
premier ministre parce qu'il
était trop froid.
- Il donnait la main à son fils!
- Il a fait son chemin.
Il parle français, et cherche
souvent ces mots, c'est un peu
comme disait Gaston Miron du...
ça c'est pas très difficile dans
les débats parce qu'il va être
avec des gens assez costauds. Et
cela, on l'a vu, il est plus
hésitant, il est plus nerveux et
s'il veut faire des gains au
Québec je ne sais pas s'il va
voir l'état d'avoir un tuteur
dans son avion. Il faudrait
qu'il retravaille son français.
- Une sur peut-être moins
inspirant et c'est vrai que
c'est quelqu'un qui ressemble
beaucoup en termes de Stephen
Harper, mais quelqu'un qui n'est
pas nécessairement à l'aise en
public, quelqu'un qui ne va pas
devant les électeurs. C'est
quelqu'un qui est la base
réservée, timide et est-ce qu'on
sera capable de décoincer Andrew
Scheer. Je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de penser que le plus
gros problème de Andrew Scheer
c'est Jagmeet Singh. Le vote du
NPD en baisse, c'est les
libéraux qui peuvent en
profiter.
- Yves-François Blanchet et avec
ses candidats il va faire un
point de presse un peu plus
tard. Ça va mieux au bloc et
j'entendais Julie Marceau qui
disait qu'ils faut veulent
tripler leur députation.
- C'est la faiblesse de Monsieur
Blanchet. Il reconstruit le bloc
il a mis fin au débat interne,
mais il faut qui se méfie de
lui-même, parce que cinq
passionnés, c'est un sanguin et
des fois il sort des choses.
Façade Jagmeet Singh, il faut
faire très attention, sur toutes
les signes religieux. Le bloc a
changé de locomotive. Comme la
locomotive va très mal, on a vu
que Monsieur Blanchet a recentré
sur les intérêts du Québec, plus
nationalistes. Il s'accroche à
la locomotive de la CAQ est
vraiment ils s'inscrivent dans
toutes les thématiques de la
CAQ. C'est quelque chose qui
était fondé pour vivre jusqu'à
la fin de l'indépendance.
Maintenance accroche un parti
qui n'est pas souverainiste.
Donc, c'est vraiment, il a
complètement largué la
locomotive péquiste, pour
prendre la locomotive caquiste.
Ça peut être payant.
- Il y a Nantel qui dit dans
Verts qui les propos
indépendance. Ils avaient aussi
connu pour faire des
déclarations inouïes.
- Il en discussion avec le
gouverneur général, il demande
la dissolution de la chambre des
communes. Ce qui peut jouer pour
le bloc ici si jamais, est-ce
que vous allez défendre ce que
sont contre la loi sur la
laïcité. S'il est trop parti
sont forcés d'entrer dans cette
danse la. Monsieur Blanchet va
pouvoir appuyer cela.
- L'outil car Monsieur Blanchet
c'est que si Monsieur Trudeau
reste au pouvoir qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire au lendemain de
votre élection en réponse au
projet de loi 21.
- Je pense que les le Koroki est
très motivé par identitaire et
qu'esquisser un argument aussi
valable en campagne électorale,
Pauline Marois arrêté au pouvoir
plus longtemps. Je pense que les
gens aiment des bateaux de ce
débat et quand ils arrivent au
moment de voter, il ne veut pas
en fonction de cela. Mulcair a
eu l'air déconnecté des intérêts
des Québécois.
- Il y a la question de
l'ingérence fédérale dans le
provincial. Il y a des Québécois
qui ne sont peut-être pas
souverainistes, mais cela ne
respecte pas la séparation des
pouvoirs entre le fédéral et le
provincial.
- Christian Noël faisait avec du
Jagmeet Singh. Depuis le début
M. Singh doit être découragé si
il nous écoute, parce que
vraiment la tâche paraît
insupportable pour le chef du
NPD et lui, l'Ontario il doit
protéger au moins ses acquis là-
bas. Et essayer de faire
quelques gains.
- S'il NPD semble en difficulté,
il faudrait lever aux partisans
parce qu'on sent un optimisme et
une effervescence oui le
déclenchement des élections et
se faire remonter les bulles
mais sont convaincus que leurs
débutants sortants qui ne se
représentent pas les Nzima
dessinent pour conserver la
ville de London. Et espère faire
des gains en Ontario. M. Singh
est ici dans le long d'une parce
que venant sa campagne sur le
thème des inégalités, de la
lutte pour pour les vols contre
les plus riches et c'est pour ça
que plutôt cette semaine ils ont
annoncé l'imposition d'une taxe
pour les super riche. Mais M.
Singh se retrouve un peu pris de
court par les révélations ce
matin de SNC-Lavalin qui lui
donne des miliciens, d'ailleurs
M. Singh a envoyé un tweet pour
dénoncer ce qui se passe. Il
lance un appel à la vérité.
Justin Trudeau devrait
s'arranger déjà et non du côté
de ses amis. Les gens qui ont
des choses à dire concernant ce
de la GRC sur la possible
obstruction dans les sorts de
Lavalin il faudrait demander au
conseil privé de donner la
directive de lever la conscience
telle ministérielle pour que
l'enquête avant. L'histoire des
SNC-Lavalin n'était pas dans les
plaisirs ce matin, mais ça lui
donne des munitions pour
s'attaquer aux problèmes de
vérité et de transparence.
- Merci Christian. Ils vont
faire campagne avec toute
l'énergie dont ils sont
capables. Mais les astres sont
moins mises joliment. Laurence
Martin du côté de Vancouver. Les
verts vont-ils utiliser tous les
symboles pour gagner.
- Oui un Orcades géant
gonflable. Dans ce débat sur
l'enjeu du pipeline, ça beau
petit clin d'oeil ce matin du
Parti vert et Patrice est très
important dans Colombie-
Britannique. L'enjeu c'est
l'environnement, les libéraux la
dernière fois avait remporté 40
% des sièges devant le NPD et
devant les conservateurs et
devant les verts. On le sait
tous ils ont acheté un pipeline
donc célébrité nos Colombiens
vont vouloir revoter pour les
libéraux ou est-ce qu'ils vont
se tourner vers les NPD, vers
les verts et surveiller la
performance des conservateurs.
C'est un ange à surveiller.
- On rappelle que Madame B va
faire un point de presse. Donc
M. Trudeau je vous rappelle avec
le gouverneur général depuis 10
minutes il devra faire son
arrivée et il va faire un
discours et il y aura ensuite
période de questions. Ça donne
le ton, rappelez-vous Madame
Marois qui avait déclenché un
peu plus tôt et on dit que les
discours les gens n'étaient pas
sa et n'avait pas fait : 13 est-
ce qu'elle avait elle avait
traîné ça. C'est pourtant un bon
départ pour les chefs.
- Les gens ne sont pas attentifs
pendant 40 jours. La première et
la dernière semaine sont très
importantes. Il peut se passer
plusieurs choses dans une
campagne fédérale.
- Assurance médicaments?
- Ailleurs le prix du médicament
a beaucoup augmenté dans les
dernières années et c'est une
préoccupation des gens et cela
fait parti des débats qu'il va y
avoir.
- C'est très concret très réel.
- C'est d'encadrer la conférence
comment est-ce que M. Trudeau va
anticiper les attaques de ses
adversaires et les répondre
avant qu'ils ont la chance de
poser la question c'est très
compliqué. C'est le premier et
c'est très important.
- Il doit communiquer aux
Canadiens son désir de les
emmener plus loin. De continuer
à améliorer leur qualité de vie.
Qui je suis moi Justin Trudeau
et si vous me donnez un deuxième
mandat, voici où j'aimerais vous
emmener tous ensemble. Et
pendant la campagne on verra
comment. C'est très important,
parce que demander un deuxième
mandat, c'est comme demander
quelqu'un en mariage.... ce
n'est plus les papillons du
début, qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
pour resituer le parti. Il faut
faire plus d'efforts pour
séduire.
- Sans tomber dans les travers
qu'on lui a reprochés. M.
Trudeau a compris qu'il ne
pouvait pas aller dans la
caricature. Trop c'était trop.
- Souvenez-vous de l'homme
s'était infiltré dans
l'égalisation et qui avait déjà
été condamné. On n'a pas voulu
rencontrer le gouvernement
indien avant plusieurs jours, il
a été boudé pendant plusieurs
jours par le premier ministre.
Il reconnaît que ce voyage en
Inde a  a mal été.
- Et d'ailleurs les cours de
sondage, après le voyage en Inde
a été plus marqué qu'après
l'affaire SNC-Lavalin. En termes
de points de pourcentage. On
revient la facilité de
comprendre et tous les Canadiens
voyait et c'était spectaculaire,
comment un premier ministre
n'était pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'on voulait.
- La personne voyait regarder ça
se demander qu'est-ce que sa.
Dans un sens avait un référendum
sur les quatre années de M.
Trudeau. Alors, il doit être en
mesure de défendre son bilan et
dire ce qu'on atteint.
- Il a en grande discussion avec
Mme Payette est là depuis 10
heures cinq. C'est dans les
longues rencontres et on attaque
le temps d'aller voir Philippe
Vincent Foisy. Il est rare
- C'est un rassemblement
partisan à Vancouver.
Il y a des sièges néodémocrate
que les libéraux espèrent
gagner. Ils veulent aussi
conserver leurs acquis à
Vancouver. Comme José le disait,
dès le départ de cette campagne,
on va vouloir faire bonne
impression. On veut courtiser
les Canadiens. On a plus l'effet
de nouveauté ou de changement.
On ne se bat plus contre l'usure
du pouvoir d'un autre parti. On
va dès le départ donné
énormément de promesses. On va
donner toutes les nouvelles
promesses électorales dans les
premières semaines de la
campagne électorale pour envoyer
le message qu'on n'est pas là
pour défendre un bilan mais pour
avoir une nouvelle offre pour
inciter les Canadiens à se
rendre aux urnes le 21 octobre.
On va aussi sillonner le pays.
On sera à Vancouver ce soir, au
Québec d'ici la fin de la
semaine et Justin Trudeau veut
se promener comme ça beaucoup
dès le départ pour vraiment
sillonner le pays et montrer
qu'il n'y a rien encore que l'on
peut tenir pour acquis.
C'est sûr que l'on va avoir des
luttes avec les semaines qui
vont se rapprocher. On va aller
dans les circonscriptions où on
pense pouvoir gagner. On va
aller là où on espère pouvoir
les conserver. Justin Trudeau
veut trouver une façon de
courtiser les électeurs mais
aussi de leur dire qu'on a fait
certaines erreurs. Il y a
l'affaire SNC-Lavalin. On veut
être capable de tasser cela pour
parler des nouvelles promesses
et mesures. On a une nouvelle
offre. On n'est pas les libéraux
de 2015. Vous choisissez
d'avancer. C'est le slogan
libéral sous le nom de Justin
Trudeau. Avec nous, on avance.
Si vous allez avec les
conservateurs, on recule.
- Mathématiquement, c'est
intéressant. Conserver tous les
sièges en Atlantique et dans les
maritimes, c'est illusoire. Il y
aura des pertes. Il y a une
marge de manoeuvre. La majorité
est 170. Ce que l'on perd en
Atlantique, on doit le gagner
soit au Québec ou en Ontario.
Dans les prairies, on ne se fait
pas beaucoup d'illusions. En
Alberta encore moins. La
Colombie-Britannique sera un
terrain important.
- On veut faire des gains. On
pensait capable d'aller chercher
une dizaine de circonscriptions.
Mathématiquement, ce sera
difficile que tous les partis
gagnent 10 ou 15
circonscriptions Québec. La
bataille du Québec sera bien
important. La majorité va se
décider au Québec si les
libéraux ou les conservateurs
seront majoritaires ou
minoritaires. À Toronto, ce sera
un enjeu crucial pour la
campagne électorale. La
Colombie-Britannique, c'est
peut-être la province qui va
nous tenir en haleine le plus
tard dans la soirée. Les
électeurs vont aller aux urnes
un peu plus tard à cause des
fuseaux horaires. On sera tenu
en haleine le 21 octobre au
soir. On va voir il y aura
combien de circonscriptions pour
les libéraux pour les
conservateurs. Est-ce que Jody
Wilson-Raybould va garder sa
circonscription? Ce sera une
bataille très serrée. Elle se
présente comme indépendant. Pour
le NPD, c'est peut-être la
province qui va leur permettre
de rester un parti reconnu à la
chambre des communes. Si on
regarde les chiffres, ça ne va
pas bien nécessairement pour le
néodémocrate. Justin Trudeau vêt
aller chercher les
circonscriptions et les
électeurs. Pour cela, il a
besoin de leur dire de voter
pour lui pour plus que ce que
l'on a fait. Oui, il y a
l'environnement, oui on a
beaucoup parlé de Trans
Mountain. N'oubliez pas tout le
reste. Voici ce que l'on va
faire en matière
d'environnement. On parle
également d'assurances
médicaments et de contrôle des
armes à feu. Les libéraux
veulent aller de l'avant avec
des mesures strictes. Les
mesures fiscales aussi. On va
beaucoup parler de classe
moyenne encore une fois. Comment
on va les aider, comment on va
répondre aux préoccupations des
Canadiens qui sont inquiets par
rapport au coût de la vie. C'est
beau les indicateurs de chômage
et d'emploi, le PIB et autres,
mais on sent qu'il y a une
crainte quand même chez les
Canadiens. Ça, Justin Trudeau
veut miser là-dessus aussi.
- L'avion de Justin Trudeau aura
plus de chances que celui
d'Andrew Scheer. M. Trudeau s'en
va à Vancouver. Ça devrait être
plus facile. La météo est bonne
là-bas. Ça fait parti des
imprévus de campagne pour les
déplacements. On va vous suivre
tout au long de cette campagne.
Oui, on attend M. Trudeau. Il
est 10 heures 35.
Il y a une question de
politesse. On ne veut pas aller
trop vite. Ce n'est pas comme si
Mme Payette réfléchissait.
- Ce n'est pas Michaëlle Jean!
On se souvient que quand elle
avait reçu M. Harper, ça avait
duré plus que deux heures,
quelque chose comme ça.
- On ne reviendra pas sur tout
ça. Finalement, ça n'a pas eu
lieu.
Jagmeet Singh se dit quoi ce
matin? Il ne faut pas enterrer
trop vite? Il y a des dynamiques
dans les provinces qui font
qu'il n'est pas mon totalement.
- Il regarde ou les autres
chaînes vont faire campagne
aujourd'hui. Ils sont donc tous
dans des circonscriptions
néodémocrate. Les libéraux, les
conservateurs à Trois-Rivières.
Vous avez le bloc et François
Blanchet. Et le néodémocrate
sont dans leur propre
circonscription à London. Vous
regardez où vont les chefs
aujourd'hui. Du côté de Jagmeet
cinq, il est en défensive. Tous
les autres veulent manger son
lunch.
C'est quelqu'un qui aime les
électeurs. Il y a une facilité
avec les gens. Il peut
surprendre. Il a des attentes
basses en ce moment. Le vent de
face est important.
- Celle qui veut ravir la
troisième place, la voilà. On
l'écoute.
- Écoutez, le premier ministre
arrive et il lance sa propre
campagne. Moi, je vais le voir
pour que je puisse l'entendre.
Et donc, ce qui peut aussi
arriver, on ne sait jamais s'il
va parler, apparemment, Andrew
Scheer a son propre plan de
match pour cet après-midi. Oui,
écoutez, si vous avez des
renseignements, Andrew Scheer et
dans un avion. D'accord, merci.
C'est la primeur. Jagmeet Singh,
je crois savoir qu'il n'est pas
dans un avion. Le bloc
québécois... après le NPD. Et
ensuite, ils vont venir nous
voir. C'est pourquoi ils sont
tous là avec leur caméra. C'est
pourquoi vous êtes là. Au moment
où le bloc québécois et il
François Blanchet...
donc nous allons nous affoler,
nous allons être très
enthousiasmés. Ne perdez pas
votre temps à m'applaudir
maintenant. Je pense que chacun
devrait savoir...
(applaudissements)
je suis à la télé maintenant?
C'est bon à savoir.
Voilà. Je suis là. Je vous
explique donc le parti vert
reste dans la réalité.
Alors bonjour Rosie.
Nous allons revenir car nous
avons beaucoup de candidats
remarquables et et ensuite nous
allons le lancement. Je pense
que nous devions vous le dire.
Je ne savais pas ce qui se
passait jusqu'à ce
que je me branche.-
Je réponds aux questions des
médias.
Je suis vraiment dans la
gratitude que vous
vous êtes levé aussitôt.
Je vous remercie pour votre
dévouement.
Vous avez dû être présent à
l'hôtel à six heures 45 ce
matin. Nous allons nous
rassembler, je vais vous
présenter les candidats. Je veux
voir ce que les autres vont
dire. Est-ce que ça va tout le
monde? Donc on se reprend. Cela
veut également dire que si vous
êtes comme moi, je n'ai pas
amené du café.
- Élisabeth May
qui parle candidement.
Elle ne savait pas qu'elle était
diffusée. Elle a dit oui, je
suis à la télé en direct.
Restons vrais, c'est ce qui
compte.
- Un moment donné, il faut être
en accord avec ce que l'on
souhaite.
- C'est son style. Elle est
charmante en dépit du fait
qu'elle est politicienne depuis
longtemps, elle donne
l'impression de l'anti
politicienne.
- En même temps,
elles a de grandes ambitions
sont parties cette fois-ci. Il
me semble que c'est formel.
C'est le déclenchement de la
campagne. Oui, ce n'est pas un
parti dans un salon.
- Vous avez des nouvelles du
premier ministre. Le chef
libéral plutôt.
C'est dans quelques minutes.
- On nous a donné deux minutes
de préavis. Il doit rester
quelque secondes maintenant.
Élisabeth May a dit qu'elle
devait parler après les autres
chefs. C'est ce qu'elle était en
train de raconter à ses
militants. Elle n'est pas
conforme au politicien
traditionnel. C'est ce qui peut
peut-être l'aider. Il y a des
électeurs qui sont peut-être
agacés de voir les politiciens
se comporter tout le temps de la
même façon. Élisabeth May à son
style et elle l'assume. Elle
aura essayé de rester intègre à
ce que les généralement.
C'est celle que je connais
depuis plusieurs années. Comme
quoi cette attention renouvelée
aux parties vert
ne l'aura pas changée
c'était du classique Élisabeth
May.
Son tour devrait venir plus
tard. Elle ne savait pas qu'elle
était devant la télé.
Il faut dire des choses avec
lesquelles on est à l'aise.
Mais Patrice, voilà, on nous dit
que Justin Trudeau sept à
l'instant.
- M. Trudeau va s'adresser aux
Canadiens pour lancer la
campagne officiellement. Un
petit discours. Ensuite, il
répondra aux questions. Sophie
Grégoire fera parti de la
campagne fédérale à temps plein.
On les a vus plutôt dans leur
vie de famille.
Justin Trudeau.
- J'aimerais que l'on se
rappelle les victimes d'il y a
18 ans. Les milliers
deux personnes qui ont été
assassinées.
À mesure que nous nous préparons
à exercer notre droit
démocratique, nous nous
rappelons leur vie. Que ça
puisse être une bénédiction pour
nous tous et toutes.
Il y a quelques instants, j'ai
rencontré Son Excellence la
gouverneur général qui a accédé
à ma demande de dissoudre le
Parlement.
Les Canadiens se rendront aux
urnes le 21 octobre prochain.
Lors de chaque élection à titre
de Canadiens, nous avons des
choix importants à faire sur
l'avenir du pays.
On peut décider de cet avenir à
bâtir ensemble.
---
Dans un gouvernement
conservateur qui pense que le
Street est une réponse à tout.
Les Canadiens ont choisi une
nouvelle équipe qui était prête
à investir dans les jambes. Une
équipe qui a compris que même si
on vit dans le meilleur pays du
monde, il est toujours possible
de faire mieux. Et bien qu'il
nous reste encore énormément de
travail à faire, on a passé les
quatre dernières années à
améliorer les choses et on a le
bilan pour le prouver. La
pauvreté a chutée, le taux de
chômage figure parmi les plus
bas enregistrés au pays et la
création d'emplois est à la
hausse. Tout cela c'est parce
que notre équipe a rejeté les
coûts et l'austérité des années
Harper parce qu'à la place on a
décidé d'investir dans la classe
moyenne et dans ceux qui
travaillent fort pour en faire
parti. Nous avons investi et
nous avons réduit le fardeau
fiscal sur la classe moyenne et
augmenter ce fardeau sur les
plus riches. Nous avons arrêté
d'envoyer des chèques de
prestations aux enfants d'un
enfant millionnaire et nous
avons mis plus d'argent dans le
primaire des familles qui ont
mis plus de mal. Nous avons
renforcé le régime de pension
canadien dans un pays comme le
nôtre les aînés ne devraient pas
avoir de la misère à joindre les
deux buts. Nous avons renégocié
l'Alena et ensuite ouvrant un
axe commercial à un...
nous conservons davantage notre
nature, nous voulons et nous
nous assurons que l'eau soit
potable et Keller soit cinq car
nous devons à nous-mêmes et à
nos enfants. Nous devons occuper
de l'environnement voilà ce qui
change la vie des gens. Cet
automne, les Canadiens pourront
voter pour les gens de Canada
qu'ils veulent, dans laquelle
ils veulent vivre. Quand un
Galvan et s'inspirer des progrès
accomplis ou retournent
politique des années Harper. Les
conservateurs indices sont pour
les gens mais ensuite dans les
services. Ce n'est pas en
coupant qu'on va s'enrichir,
c'est pourquoi notre
gouvernement a choisi de faire
avancer le pays. On a choisi
d'investir dans les familles,
dans les travailleurs et dans
notre communauté. On a choisi de
faire confiance aux Canadiens.
Au cours des quatre dernières
années, plus d'un million de
nouveaux emplois est été créé.
On a négocié de nouveaux accords
sur la santé avec les provinces
et les territoires. On a
introduit la nouvelle allocation
canadienne des enfants qui
aident les parents à l'92 aux
parents.é...
on a sorti 900 000 Canadiens de
la pauvreté dont 300 000
enfants. Sous un gouvernement
libéral, le Canada va continuer
d'avancer. Au bout du compte, la
politique est bien ça concerne
les gens, peut-être êtes-vous
diplômé, ni aux Canadiens, peut-
être avez-vous des enfants ou à
la retraite. Qui que vous soyez
vous mérité un vrai plan pour
votre avenir nous avons beaucoup
accompli depuis quatre ans
depuis quatre ans mais la vérité
c'est que nous ne faisons que
commencer. Les Canadiens ont
échoué important prendre, alors
reculer aux politiques du passé
ou continu d'aller la voir.
Voilà le choix. C'est aussi
clair que cela. Et c'est
important. Moi, je veux que nous
puissions aller de l'avant pour
chacun et chacune d'entre nous.
- Bonjour premier ministre,
qu'est-ce que vous cédez cacher
en levant la confidence et pour
que la GRC puisse faire enquête
sur votre rôle et le votre
bureau dans le scandale SNC-
Lavalin?
- Écoutez, nous avons été
responsables du plus grand
comment dire secret dans
l'histoire du Canada...
- mais vous êtes le patron, vous
êtes dans le point de mire.
Allez-vous demander à lever la
confidentialité?
- Nous respectons les décisions
pris par nos fonctionnaires et
nous respectons la décision du
greffier.
- Bonjour, je suis curieuse,
vous étiez aujourd'hui en disant
que les conservateurs ne sont
pas nos ennemis et pourtant
votre parti s'attaque, est en
train de démonisaient les
conservateurs. Que dites-vous à
vos enfants quand vous parlez
d'Andrew Scheer?
- Je vais être très clair sur
les différences politiques. Les
Canadiens méritent d'avoir des
contrastes clairs entre une
vision qui est ouverte et
inclusive et respectueuse des
droits de chacun et une
perspective qui se dit pour le
peuple, mais qui réduit les
services et les impôts pour les
riches. Je serai toujours très
clair que je ne ferai pas
d'attaques personnelles, mais je
vais être pointu sur les
différences en matière de
politique, nous visions pour le
pays sont très différentes,
entre l'approche libérale qui
inclusive et l'approche
conservatrice qui veulent prôner
DB Cooper et de l'austérité. Et
on veut mettre ça au clair.
- Sur SNC-Lavalin vous avez dit
que vous assumez la
responsabilité de de cela mais
que vous n'êtes pas en accord
avec le commissaire à l'éthique.
Vous n'avez jamais Canadiens ce
que vous avez fait comme erreur.
- En tant que premier ministre
j'ai dû défendre les emplois du
Canada, je vais toujours
défendre l'emploi. J'étais tout
à fait clair là-dessus continue
de le faire.
- Donc aucune erreur???
- Vous avez déclenché une
élection et pourquoi vous
demandez Ockenden ou faire
confiance quand on ne connaît
pas tous les détails de
l'affaire SNC-Lavalin. Il est
question d'un comité qui
bloquait l'enquête.
- Nous avons promis va faire
augmenter l'économie et nous
avons livré la marchandise et
nous avons vu plus d'un million
d'emplois créés en quatre,
pendant que 900 000 Canadiens
ont pu dire au revoir à la
pauvreté. Notre engagement
investi dans les communautés à
payer et à offrir des réactions
de succès aux autochtones, grâce
à la réconciliation. La
croissance économique et la
protection de l'environnement
peut allumer dans la main et ce
n'est pas un ou l'autre. Voilà
les éléments auxquelles on s'est
engagé et c'est exactement ce
que nous avons fait depuis
quatre ans déjà, nous sommes les
premiers à reconnaître qu'il
reste beaucoup à faire et j'ai
vraiment hâte de parler aux
Canadiens et aux Canadiennes
d'un océan à l'autre à propos de
nos plans pour continuer de
bâtir un meilleur Canada à
mesure que nous avançons tous
ensemble.
- En ce 18e anniversaire des
attentats de New York, c'est
peut-être un manque de
sensibilité de déclencher ces
élections.
- L'exercice de nos droits
fondamentaux, le moment de
s'engager sur la réflexion d'un
avenir meilleur pour chacun,
c'est une valeur profonde et
nous la célébrons. Ce sont à la
fois des moments où nous pensons
au succès et aux insuccès du
passé et aux tragédies, nous
pensons familles touchées par
ces attentats terribles d'il y a
18 ans et nous allons de l'avant
et nous nous engageons tous les
jours à une seule société plus
juste et plus sûre pour chacun.
- Paul Adams loi arrêtée au
Québec et la question
maintenant, si vous êtes reporté
au pouvoir est-ce que votre
gouvernement va constater
contester judiciairement ou
s'impliquer dans une
contestation judiciaire?
- Je suis en désaccord avec la
loi 21 et je ne trouve pas que
dans une société libre, on doit
légitimer ou permettre la
discrimination contre quiconque.
Je suis très content que des
Québécois eux-mêmes soient en
train de contester cette loi,
soit en train de défendre la loi
canadienne. Nous suivons de
proche tout ce qu'il faut se
fait et nous regardons
attentivement ce processus, mais
pour l'instant, nous trouvons
pas, nous trouvons que c'est
contre productif pour un
gouvernement fédéral de
s'impliquer dans cette cause.
Comme je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises je suis profondément
contre la loi 21 au Québec et je
ne crois pas que ce dans une
société libre on devrait
permettre ou légitimer la
discrimination quelle qu'elle
soit. Je suis fort content que
les Québécois ont décidé eux-
mêmes de contester cette loi
devant les tribunaux, de
défendre la charte des droits et
libertés. J'ai observé cela de
très près et j'ai envisagé des
gestes que le gouvernement
fédéral préposé mais pour
l'instant je pense que c'est
contre productif pour nous de
nous engager dans cette lutte.
- Est-ce que cette décision est
définitive?
- Je suis situation de proche,
mais je ne pense pas que c'est
encore quelque chose de
productif. Nous suivons de très
près le processus et nous
pensons que ce n'est pas
productif pour le fédéral de
s'engager dans cette contre-
passation judiciaire 21, mais
nous suivons la situation de
près et nous allons évaluer
notre.
- Les Moulineaux sont les plus
importants blocs d'électeurs.
Comment gagner la confiance des
jeunes parce que vous aviez
promis la différence, mais vous
êtes montré tout à fait pareil
au politicien du passé
interrogation
- Les milléniums ont vu les
changements, on a crée de la
richesse à mesure que nous
avançons est bien on est
vraiment le gouvernement le plus
ambitieux quant à la protection
de l'environnement. Tout en
s'assurant la croissance
économique. Nous allons parler
de plate-forme très ambitieuse
qui visera à une confiance
encore plus grande envers ce
grand et beau pays.
- Pouvez-vous expliquer pourquoi
vous dîtes que c'est contre-
productif de s'opposer à la loi
21 au Québec. Qu'est-ce que vous
surveillez dans ce débat?
- Dans une société libre on ne
devrait pas être en train de
suspendre des droits
fondamentaux, on ne devrait pas
être en train de permettre et
délégitimer la discrimination
contre les citoyens basés sur la
religion ou sur d'autres choses.
C'est pour cela que nous sommes
préoccupés évidemment par se
protège de droite. Comme j'ai
dit, les Québécois eux-mêmes
sont en train d'emmener des
contestation judiciaire, sont en
train de défendre la Chartres
des droits et libertés et en
tant que Québécois, en tant que
gouvernement fédéral nous
surveillons de près ce processus
et nous regardons comment et si
le gouvernement fédéral a besoin
ou devrait intervenir et ce, ma
décision pour l'instant que je
crois ce serais contre-productif
de s'immiscer dans le processus
légal à ce moment-ci.
- Est-ce que c'est la question
que cette loi est contestée
jusqu'au bout, si c'est ce que
vous... qui part d'une question
référendaire sur le climat.
Comment est-ce que vous espérez
vous distinguer, vous ne
craignez pas que ce vote
s'éparpille?
- Les Canadiens comprennent très
bien que le réchauffement
climatique est une menace réelle
qui peut nuire aussi à notre
économie. C'est pour ça que nous
avons un plan qui agit de façon
concrète pour mieux protéger
l'environnement que tout autre
gouvernement dans l'histoire de
notre pays. Mais en même temps,
il prépare nos familles, nos
jeunes, nos travailleurs pour un
avenir dans lequel les nouveaux
emplois vont être liés à une
économie plus verte et plus
propre. Nous avons un plan
ambitieux et pour protéger
l'environnement et pour faire
croître l'économie. C'est ce que
nous avions démontré au cours
des quatre dernières années. Je
trouve ça dommage que les
conservateurs ne comprennent
encore pas que les changements
climatiques sont une menace
réelle à laquelle il va falloir
affronter concrètement. Encore
une fois on voit les politiciens
conservateurs à travers le pays
dépensait de l'argent du public
pas pour aider dans la
transformation mais pour
contester un plan qui fonctionne
pour les Canadiens. Nous allons
continuer de démontrer par nos
actions et par nos engagements
que les Canadiens s'attendent à
du leadership concret, un
gouvernement convaincu que
d'agir contre les changements
climatiques c'est la seule façon
de protéger les générations
futures et de créer l'économie
nécessaire pour l'avenir.
- La loi 21, vous attendez la
Cour suprême?
- Nous allons suivre ce qui se
passe dans le processus
judiciaire et nous allons
prendre nos décisions au fur et
à mesure si on va intervenir
mais comme j'ai dit je trouve
que ce serait contre-productif
d'intervenir à ce moment.
- Toujours sur le même thème.
Vous avez dit pour l'instant, je
me demandais si cette décision
va tenir que vous soyez
minoritaire ou majoritaire?
- Nous allons toujours faire ce
qui est nécessaire pour défendre
les droits de tous les Canadiens
au Québec comme partout au
Canada. Les gens apprécient
cette charte des droits et
libertés qui protègent nos
libertés fondamentales et je
sais qu'il y a bien des
Québécois qui trouvent que dans
une société libre on ne devrait
pas légitimer et la
discrimination contre quiconque.
- Qu'est-ce que vous répondez
aux gens qui vous accusent de
compromettre vos valeurs de
diversité et d'inclusion pour ne
pas offusquer les Québécois
actuellement?
- J'ai toujours été extrêmement
clair. Je suis en désaccord avec
ce projet de loi 21. Ma
responsabilité en tant que
premier ministre c'est toujours
d'assurer la défense des droits
de tous les Canadiens. C'est
pour ça que je suis très content
que les Québécois eux-mêmes sont
en train de contester cette loi
devant la cour.
(en anglais)
- vous entamez la campagne de
Vancouver. Comme c'est juste à
côté de la circonscription de
votre ancienne collègue et
rival, Jody Wilson-Raybould,
qu'en est-il.
- Vous vous rappellerez qu'il y
avait beaucoup de gens qui
étaient rassemblés ici un peu
partout dans la ville qui ont
critiqué que c'était une grande
erreur de ne pas être ici à
Ottawa pour le lancement de la
campagne électorale libérale.
Nous avons démontré que les
campagnes se passent sur le
terrain. Le lancement d'une
campagne dans mon deuxième
foyer, la Colombie Britannique,
c'est tout à fait bons en 2015,
et j'ai très hâte de me rendre
en Colombie Britannique cet
après-midi et d'être un peu
partout au pays dans les
semaines à venir. Il y a
beaucoup de Canadiens
rencontrés. C'est un choix
important qu'ils ont à faire.
Allons-nous vers l'avenir où
nous nous tournons vers le
passé? Je sais que les Canadiens
sont enthousiasmés par les
occasions qui s'offrent à nous
et j'ai hâte de me remonter les
manches pour travailler pour eux
tous les jours.
En 2015 on a choisi de lancer
notre campagne électorale à
Vancouver malgré le fait que
plusieurs personnes disaient que
c'était une erreur de ne pas
être à Ottawa pour le lancement
de la campagne. Nous avions
démontré qu'une campagne
électorale se fait à travers le
pays et pas juste à Ottawa.
C'est pour ça que je suis si
content d'aller à Vancouver, mon
deuxième chez-moi, pour lancer
la campagne cet après-midi. Dans
les semaines à venir nous allons
nous retrouver partout au pays
pour avoir ces conversations
importantes avec les Canadiens
sur quel choix ils vont faire
pour les années à venir. Est-ce
qu'on va continuer d'avancer ou
est-ce qu'on va retourner en
arrière vers les années Harper?
- Vos adversaires vous attaquent
sur le plan de l'éthique.
Comment réagissez-vous à l'idée
que vous n'êtes pas authentique
à cet égard?
- Je pense que les Canadiens
savent très bien que je polarise
mon attention sur les choix pour
les Canadiens pour aller de
l'avant l'avantage de la classe
moyenne, sur la question de la
réconciliation avec les
autochtones que la seule façon
de bâtir une économie solide
c'est de bâtir l'environnement,
les deux vont de pair. Nous
sommes à 100 % dévoués un
meilleur avenir et c'est
pourquoi nous voulons aller de
l'avant. Merci.
(en anglais)
- c'est passé officiellement
cette campagne électorale. 40
jours de campagne. Justin
Trudeau a fait un discours et a
répondu aux questions. Il se
pose clairement comme le leader
progressiste versus
l'alternative conservatrice qui
veut dit-il faire revenir les
Canadiens en arrière et que lui
seul peut continuer la marche
qu'il a entrepris il y a quatre
ans maintenant. L'économie s'est
améliorée, revenu des gens s'est
amélioré, dit-il,
l'environnement est une vraie
bataille. Les questions beaucoup
portées sur la loi 21 au Québec.
Va-t-il comme champion des
droits individuels aidait les
opposants à cette loi sur la
laïcité au Québec? Aller devant
les tribunaux? Va-t-il
participer à cette bataille
devant les tribunaux? La
réponse, pour l'instant, le
gouvernement fédéral ne sera pas
un partenaire actif aux luttes
devant les tribunaux. Pour
l'instant. Tour de table avant
d'aller retrouver nos ex que je
vais vous présenter pour la
campagne. Ce qu'il est clair,
c'est qu'elle se cambre comme
étant le seul progressiste qui a
les chances de remporter. En
faisant référence bien sûre à
ses opposants. Il se pose comme
étant le seul rempart contre le
danger de retour en arrière.
- La dernière fois le vote
progressiste, vote des jeunes et
le vote des femmes c'était
regroupé autour de lui. Il parle
d'avancer, d'aider la classe
moyenne, il essaie de
reconstituer la coalition qui
lui a permis de remporter à
l'époque. Mais il est le
gouvernement sortant est le
point de presse est un peu plus
compliqué lorsqu'ils étaient
troisièmes dans les intentions
de vote. La loi 21, et d'autres
questions. La manière dont
pourra se défendre sur
différents sujets comme SNC-
Lavalin vont teinter la campagne
électorale. La campagne boit
être scénarisée, c'est la
manière dont on réagit aux
questions des journalistes et à
ce qui peut surgir de
l'actualité qui fait qu'on peut
avoir ou non une campagne
électorale positive.
- Sans confirmer ce que je
disais au début. Il prend le
camp progressiste. Il parle au
néo démocrate et au verre il dit
qu'il est au pouvoir, qu'il est
celui qui a le plus de chances
de rester au pouvoir, il faut
voter pour lui.
Sa première référence dans son
discours était à l'économie. Il
parle directement à Andrew Sheer
quand elle fait ça. Il dit que
nous investissons dans les
Canadiens, le déficit. Bravo. Et
c'est l'austérité les
compressions, c'est ce qu'il dit
les conservateurs.
- Les ontariens vont écouter ça
parce qu'ils le vivent avec
Monsieur Ford.
- Sur la loi 21 il était très
habile. Il doit parler en même
temps au Canada anglais au
Québec et dire la même chose. Ça
doit être cohérent. Il a réussi
à le faire. Quand il dit pour
l'instant, il parle au Canada
anglais. Il leur laisse l'espoir
que s'il est réélu il va suivre
le processus au point de s'en
mêler. Au Québécois, il y a une
phrase clé quand il a dit : il
n'y a pas un québécois qui ne
sait pas que je suis opposé à la
loi 21. C'est connu, ma position
est connue et s'il avait voulu
badiner mais il ne pouvait pas,
il dit qu'il est quand même au
sommet des sondages au Québec.
C'est connu, pour lui, ce ne
sera pas un handicap. Il a été
très clair sur la loi 21.
Il a laissé les sports aux
Canadiens anglais avec son pour
l'instant.
- Pas pour les prochains 40
jours parce que ce serait
contre-productif parce qu'il
perdrait des votes. Il sait que
ses opposants aussi ne vont pas
toucher à ça alors il est sur un
terrain assez sûr. Ses
adversaires ne sont pas Andrew
Sheer ou Jagmeet Singh, c'est
Stephen Harper, Doug Ford et
Donald Trump. Il a fait
allusion. Il a dit que les
conservateurs sont des Ford
people, mais ils vivent ensuite
des coupeurs. Il gens ne veulent
pas quelqu'un qui ne peuvent pas
prédire comme Donald Trump,
quelqu'un qui dit quelque chose
autre chose le lendemain. Le
plus important est Stephen
Harper. Il fait une énorme
révision historique. Il dit que
c'est à cause de l'austérité que
l'économie ne marchait pas.
C'est la chute du prix du
pétrole qui a provoqué tout ça,
pas Stephen Harper. Les gens
n'ont pas peur d'Andrew Sheer
mais de Stephen Harper. C'est
très spécifique.
- Beaucoup de questions sur SNC-
Lavalin aussi. Quelle erreur
avez-vous commise? Soyez plus
précis. Allez vous le libérer le
secret des ministres qui
puissent collaborer davantage
avec la GRC? On sent que cette
mouche ne s'en ira pas non plus
par magie.
- J'imagine que c'était pas
idéal pour lui c'est une du
Globe and Mail aujourd'hui quand
on parle de début de campagne
qu'on doit réussir. C'est sûr
qu'il a à défendre un bilan,
mais c'est un caillou dans son
soulier.
- On va écouter le leader du NPD
et on revient.
(en anglais)
- j'aimerais reconnaître ceux
qui ont perdu leur vie lors des
attentats d'il y a 18 ans et les
premiers répondants qui ont fait
preuve d'autant de courage. Mes
amis, nous sommes ici à London,
une ville tellement belle. J'ai
passé cinq ainsi à l'université.
J'ai des souvenirs vraiment
forts et difficiles. J'ai pu
m'occuper de mon frère, nous
avons-vous de la misère. J'ai dû
travailler juste pour joindre
les deux bouts. La famille a
aidé avec le soutien de la
nourriture et ça m'a rappelé une
valeur fort canadienne. Je
n'aurais pas pu traverser cela
sans leur soutien. C'est cela
quoi les Canadiens croient. Ils
croient que nous devons prendre
soin les uns des autres. C'est
ça la valeur canadienne profonde
à laquelle je croyais que j'ai
incarné. Vous savez tous que
j'adore le Canada. Je pense que
nous pouvons le rendre meilleur.
Plutôt aujourd'hui j'ai eu la
chance de parler avec Jessica.
Elle est enceinte et elle a
survécu au cancer. Elle a de la
difficulté, c'est difficile de
se payer les médicaments sans
remboursement des médicaments
par une assurance. C'est quelque
chose qui l'écrase. J'ai
rencontré Nancy et Jakie sont à
la retraite. Ils m'ont parlé de
leurs préoccupations sur les
dépenses qu'ils paient eux-
mêmes. Ils ne savent pas à quoi
s'attendre. Ils ne savent pas
combien ça va leur coûter pour
les soins dentaires ou des
nouvelles lunettes. Moi,
j'estime que nous pouvons mieux
nous occuper de gens comme
Jessica, Nancy et Jack.
Nous pouvons élargir la
couverture pour qu'on puisse
payer les médicaments pour tous.
Et même aller au-delà de ça.
Pour la santé mentale et les
soins des yeux.
(applaudissements)
nous pouvons le réussir. Mais
uniquement si nous avons le
courage de résister aux
lobbyistes et aux stratèges des
grandes sociétés. Nous pouvons
construire 500 000 nouvelles
résidences abordables. Nous
pouvons le faire seulement si
nous avons le courage de nous en
prendre aux blanchisseurs de
capitaux qui influencent le
prix. Nous pouvons aider les
Canadiens qui font face aux prix
élevés pour les téléphones
cellulaires et Internet.
Nous pouvons agir maintenant
pour nous aider avec le climat
et créer 300 000 nouveaux
emplois de qualité. Mais
seulement si nous avons le
courage de mettre fin aux
subventions aux carburants
fossiles.
(applaudissements)
nous vivons dans un pays où les
riches sont de plus en plus
riche. Un pays où la majorité de
la population n'a pas accès aux
mêmes avantages. Un pays où le
gouvernement conservateur et
libéraux ont créé un système qui
profite aux riches et qui laisse
tomber le reste entre nous.
Il y a quatre ans, Justin
Trudeau nous a charmé avec des
belles paroles et des promesses
vident : il disait ce qu'il
fallait dire mais il n'a rien
fait par la suite. Derrière des
portes closes, Justin Trudeau
fait tout ce que les grandes
sociétés lui imposent. C'est
tout à fait clair que Justin
Trudeau n'est pas qui il disait
être. Et Andrew Sheer et les
conservateurs ne sont pas non
plus la réponse. Ils vont
réduire les impôts pour les plus
riches et réduire les services
dont vous et vos familles ont
besoin. Vous allez payer le prix
avec des soins de santé encore
plus cher et des médicaments
encore plus chers. Une crise du
climat qui s'aggrave.
Les conservateurs et les
libéraux nous font une série de
promesses mais trop souvent, ils
ne les tiennent pas.
Quand vient le temps de choisir
entre les intérêts de la
population ou ceux des grandes
multinationales, leur choix est
clair. Ils choisissent ceux des
prêts pétrolières et les
compagnies pharmaceutiques. On
veut des résultats différents,
il faut faire des choix
différents. Dans cette élection,
ça se résume à un choix clair.
Ce qui pouvait vous conter pour
se battre pour vous.
Alors donc, cette élection c'est
un choix très clair. Qui va se
battre pour vous. Ce qui vous
pouvait compter. Quand j'étais
jeune, je ne me suis jamais
imaginé que quelqu'un qui avait
mon apparence pouvait se
présenter au poste de premier
ministre. Combien de temps les
gens m'ont dit que je ne pouvais
pas faire telle ou telle chose.
Maintenant les enfants me disent
: j'ai l'impression que je
pourrais faire n'importe quoi en
te voyant.
Ça, c'est vraiment inspirants.
Nous avons beaucoup de
possibilités à vivre dans les 40
prochaines journées. Nous allons
présenter un message d'espoir
aux Canadiens. Nous pouvons
bâtir le pays de nos rêves.
Chacun peut se sentir chez soi.
Les soins de santé quand on n'en
a besoin. De l'eau potable, de
bons emplois, un bon avenir.
Vous savez, partout où je me
rends, je rencontre des gens qui
travaillent fort, qu'ils veulent
être traités avec équité et
bâtir une bonne vie pour eux-
mêmes et leur famille. Les gens
pour lesquels les parties
néodémocrate s'est toujours
battue. C'est pour ces gens que
je suis là devant vous. Merci.
- Jagmeet Singh lance sa
campagne en voulant dire à ses
militants : nous ne sommes pas
morts. Nous allons lutter
jusqu'au bout. Oui, il y a des
questions des journalistes. On
va l'écouter assurément.
- M. Singh, les sondages sont
plus faibles qu'au moment où
Thomas Mulcair a quitté le
parti. Donc on dit que vous
allez avoir du mal à retenir le
siège que vous avez maintenant à
la chambre des communes.
- Ce que j'entends des gens,
c'est qu'ils en ont marre
des politiciens qui aident les
riches.
Je pense que nous sommes dans
cette position parce que le
gouvernement a décidé de rendre
la vie plus facile pour les
grandes pharmaceutiques. Je suis
conscient que les gens veulent
des gens qui travaillent fort
pour eux.
- Sur la portabilité à London en
Ontario, leur contrat avec des
véhicules blindés légers qui
doivent être vendus à l'Arabie
Saoudite mais que vous voulez
annuler. Que dites-vous aux
travailleurs.
- Je leur dis que le Canada a
beaucoup de besoins dans les
forces canadiennes. Nous pouvons
certainement essayer des
contrats pour notre propre
approvisionnement. Ces personnes
qui travaillent fort devraient
continuer d'avoir ces contrats
ou certainement vendre des
équipements à des pays qui ne
sont pas répressifs. S'il y a un
moment où il faudrait annuler
leur contrat militaire, c'est un
pays qu'on allègue qui est
responsable de l'assassinat d'un
journaliste qui tue des gens au
Yémen et qui en fait réprime les
droits de la personne de leurs
propres citoyens. Nous pouvons
avoir certainement ces emplois
protégés par des contrats
militaires ailleurs que dans des
pays au régime répressif.
Je m'excuse, c'était pendant les
applaudissements. J'ai manqué la
question.
- Christian Noël de Radio-
Canada. Bonjour.
La GRC a de la difficulté à
interroger les gens dans le
dossier de SNC-Lavalin.
- Ce qu'on a entendu des
ministres, ils ont dit qu'ils
ont des choses à partager mais à
cause du fait qu'ils n'ont pas
le droit de partager leur
histoire, ils n'ont plus la
chance de partager cette
histoire avec la commissaire à
l'éthique. On a eu des
reportages, le commissaire à
l'éthique a dit qu'il a été
approché par des ministres. Ils
ont voulu partager leur
histoire. Mais il ne pouvait pas
à cause du fait qu'il n'avait
pas le droit de le faire.
- Les conservateurs et les
libéraux veulent aider la classe
moyenne. Tout le monde veut le
faire. Les conservateurs et les
libéraux ont une campagne
nationale. De votre côté, les
moyens sont moins grands. Vous
avez une campagne régionalisée.
Pourquoi les gens devraient
voter pour vous.
- On a une campagne qui sera
nationale. On va agir à travers
le pays. Oui, les conservateurs
ont dit qu'ils sont là pour M.
et Mme tout le monde. Il coupe
le service donc ils ont besoin.
Il coupe les services comme les
services de santé, l'éducation.
On peut voir la preuve ici à
l'intérieur. Ils ont coupé tous
les services dont les gens
besoin. Donc c'est clair ce
qu'ils font. Et aussi, si on
regarde le bilan, c'est toujours
le cas contre la priorité de la
population et les grandes
compagnies, les conservateurs et
les libéraux choisissent les
priorités des grandes
compagnies.
Qui peut se battre pour vous. En
fait, je dis que c'est le NPD
qui a toujours montré cette
volonté de travail pour M. et
Mme tout le monde.
(applaudissements)
- j'aimerais vous poser la
question, il est question de
problèmes dans la campagne. Que
devez-vous faire afin de tourner
la page sur les obstacles et les
entraves dont on a parlé face à
votre campagne.
- Nous voulons changer comment
la politique se joue au Canada.
Depuis quelques années, nous
avons vu que le gouvernement à
Ottawa n'ont pas réagi aux
besoins des gens. Regardez le
coût des médicaments. C'est
quelque chose qui préoccupe les
Canadiens. Cela alourdit leur
vie. M. Trudeau a promis de
réduire le coût des médicaments
par un petit changement. Il a
abandonné cela. En quatre ans,
il a rencontré des lobbyistes,
plus de 875 fois. Les lobbyistes
des grandes sociétés. Par
conséquent, il a renié son
engagement. Ce n'est pas une
coïncidence. Les Canadiens et
les Canadiennes, nous nous
engageons à nous battre contre
les grandes puissances
commerciales et de nous battre
pour M. et Mme tout le monde.
- Mais vous avez des obstacles
personnels à surmonter.
- Historiquement, j'ai surmonté
des obstacles. C'est la même
chose aujourd'hui. Cela
ressemble à la vie de tout un
chacun. Les femmes par exemple
ont du mal à avancer dans leur
carrière. Elles sont sous
représentés dans la plupart des
secteurs. Que ce soit dans la
culture corporative ou dans les
universités. Les gens font face
à des barrières selon leur
orientation sexuelle, leur
langue parlée. Ce sont des défis
quotidiens pour beaucoup de
Canadiens. Je comprends ces
gens. J'espère que les gens
pourvoient en moi quelqu'un qui
veut bâtir un pays où il n'y a
pas d'obstacle. Les gens n'ont
pas à faire face assez entravent
fonder sur leur identité. Ils
peuvent vraiment offrir le
meilleur d'eux-mêmes et se
réaliser entièrement.
- Jagmeet Singh qui dit oui,
j'ai été habitué à l'adversité.
Il en aura besoin. Le NPD à 39
circonscriptions à protéger. On
ne parle pas de gains
nécessairement. Il voudrait en
faire, mais Alex nous disait au
début que quand on regarde
l'itinéraire du chef, il va
protéger ses acquis. Quelle est
la province où il y a le plus de
députés, ça reste au Québec avec
14 actuellement. Un mot rapide,
la tâche est énorme. Il en est à
sa première campagne.
- Son caucus du Québec et le
plus important mais il manquait
de français dans ce discours. Il
y a huit phrases sur 53 qui
étaient en français. Ces 15 % de
son discours. Ce n'est pas
suffisant. Je pense qu'il y aura
un ajustement à faire. À London,
il y a quand même des Québécois
qui écoutent. C'est un discours
assez classique. On parle des
travailleurs. Ça prend quand
même du courage pour dire qu'on
allait annuler un contrat avec
l'Arabie Saoudite. Il est à
London. C'est là que les 3000
emplois sont créés. Ça prenait
un certain courage. Pour le
reste, je n'étais pas surpris.
- Logement social, assurance
médicaments. Les frais, ça peut
parler au contribuable. Des
frais cellulaires trop élevés.
Il dit qu'il ne serait pas gêné
de se battre contre des grandes
corporations. Entre-temps, il y
a une bataille à faire sur le
terrain qui est loin d'être
gagné.
Je vous présente ceux qui seront
avec nous chaque semaine jusqu'à
la soirée électorale.
Yolande James
à Montréal.
Bonjour à vous quatre.
C'est parti. Un premier tour de
table rapide.
Qu'allez-vous surveiller
particulièrement dans cette
campagne qui commence?
- On va suivre la campagne du
côté du premier ministre.
Il a été capable de bien cadrer
la question qu'il souhaite entre
lui et le parti conservateur.
Il va falloir voir comment M.
Scheer s'imposera et se définir
dans la campagne.
Ce matin, je voyais l'avion.
Ça démontre à quel point il a
donné beaucoup de place à M.
Ford
et l'équipe de la résistance.
M. signe que l'on vient de voir,
c'est très difficile pour lui
malgré le fait qu'il n'a pas
suffisamment parlé en français.
- C'est au Québec qu'il a le
plus de députés.
- Mais c'est important pour lui
de ne pas sortir en panique.
Il veut s'assurer d'avoir ces
candidats prêts à faire campagne
mais effectivement il y a des
ajustements à faire au niveau du
français Silver vote québécois.
- On va écouter le chef du bloc
québécois, Yves François
Blanchet.
- On est calme.
- Je leur ai dit : je ne veux
pas entendre un mot.
Ça n'a pas marché avec
Christiane.
- Il y a des ajustements. Ils
attendent le cue.
On rappelle que Yves François
Blanchet, qui a mis la barre
haute, il veut doubler la
députation au Québec est passé
de 10 à 20. Et Julie nous disait
tantôt que l'on parle de 30. La
barre est très haute et le
travail sera difficile. Il y
aura des grosses batailles dans
le Québec francophone dans cette
élection qui commence.
Je crois qu'il est prêt.
- Mes amis québécois, bonjour.
Permettez-moi d'abord d'avoir
une pensée pour nos voisins
américains en cette date du 11
septembre, qui rappelle de bien
tristes souvenirs. Cependant,
ici, au Québec, soyez certains
que nous avions terriblement
hâte et vous n'imaginez pas le
plaisir que nous aurons, nous
les 78 candidats et candidates
du Bloc québécois au cours des
six prochaines semaines. Nous
allons avec le coeur, la passion
et la dignité qui font de nous
des Québécois vous présenter une
offre politique et nous avons
choisi de le faire à Québec
parce que Québec ou de commencer
à Québec et parce que Québec,
c'est notre seule capitale
nationale. C'est à Québec il y a
notre seul parlement national,
avec un gouvernement qui pour la
première fois depuis longtemps
et de façon majoritaire affirme,
affiche un nationalisme
décomplexé qui fait du bien.
L'élection, c'est choisir qui va
porter notre voix, qui va être
fidèle à ce que nous sommes, à
ce que vous êtes. Pas comme
province, mais bel et bien comme
nation. Des gens en qui vous
allez vous reconnaître. Des gens
qui sont comme vous autres et
des gens qui le sont pour vous
autres. Qui va parler pour le
Québec? Qui va préserver et
promouvoir les intérêts du
Québec? Qui va offrir un projet
au Québec pour le Québec? Il ne
s'agit pas tant de formuler des
attaques. Nous devons faire une
offre politique, en revanche il
y a quand même des constats à
faire parce que pour que les
Québécois se reconnaissent dans
leurs élus, il faut que ces élus
partagent les mêmes valeurs. Une
valeur d'identification profonde
à la langue française, la valeur
d'égalité entre les sexes, la
valeur importante et étonnamment
revenue dans l'actualité du
droit des femmes à disposer de
leur propre corps. La valeur
d'accueil responsable, prudent
mais généreux de l'immigration.
La valeur bien sûre et on a vu
dans les dernières minutes
commence sera atteint, la valeur
de laïcité, de l'État québécois,
qui est une valeur progressiste
héritée de la révolution
tranquille. Enfin, je le mets
dans les valeurs parce que c'en
est une qui nous distingue, la
valeur d'attachement à un
environnement sain où nous et
nos enfants pourront nous
développer et grandir. Enfin, on
ne peut pas ne pas souligner un
certain nombre de cas et de
dossier ou le Canada, au cours
des dernières années, n'a pas
servi le Québec. Je mentionnerai
évidemment la gestion de
l'offre, la gestion aussi très
douteuse de l'accueil des
réfugiés, de dizaines de
milliers de demandeurs de statut
de réfugié en Montérégie. Le
congé de taxe accordée au géant
d'Internet. Un appui tiède
encore inexistant aux médias du
Québec dans une crise sans
précédent et pourtant annoncé de
longue date. La concurrence
déloyale à l'encontre d'Hydro-
Québec en soutenant.. FAlls par
des deniers fédéraux alors qu'il
n'y a jamais faits ou donnés par
Hydro-Québec. Le secret gênant
entourant la gestion du dossier
de SNC-Lavalin. Le manque de
respect du chantier de la Davie
qui ultimement aura moins de 3 %
d'une cagnotte de plus de 100
milliards de dollars alors
qu'elle est capable de
construire la moitié de la
capacité en construction navale.
Les emplois de l'Abeos alors
qu'on nous promet que si jamais
Air Canada achète Intanza que
les emplois sont protégés et
qu'on nous demande d'y croire,
la déclaration unique d'impôt
alors que clairement cela
sauverait aux familles
québécoises des centaines de
millions de dollars. Aussi, le
Canada, c'est l'obsession
pétrolière, ces 4 milliards de
dollars, de l'argent des
Québécoises et des Québécois
envoyés pour un oléoduc qui ira
de l'Alberta la côte du
Pacifique. C'est la menace qui
revient sans cesse d'Energie Est
qui traverserait le territoire
québécois, le refus d'une
commission d'enquête pour jeter
toute la lumière nécessaire sur
le drame du Lac-Mégantic et sept
on peut faire des reproches.
Toutefois, on doit se demander
qui nous sommes, ce que l'on
veut pour nous, nos enfants et
qui nous offre le mieux pour
tout ça. Demandons-nous aussi,
justement, il ne faut pas
relancer avec vigueur cette idée
de faire du Québec un pays, un
pays normal comme tous les
autres pays. Comme l'ont proposé
René Lévesque, Jacques Parizeau,
Lucien Bouchard et Pauline
Marois avec qui j'ai eu
l'occasion de siéger. Je mets
mes adversaires au défi à leur
convenance de me parler de
souveraineté, de me parler
d'indépendance et je serai
toujours honoré de répondre à
toutes les questions contribuant
à la création d'un pays pour la
nation que je veux représenter.
L'histoire récente nous a montré
que les Québécois ont flirté si
je peux dire ainsi avec trois
partis fédéraux de façon
significative. Nous avons connu
les années Harper et avons
fermement décidé de ne pas
retourner là. Nous avons eu une
relation de quelques années avec
un nombre important de députés
du NPD et ça n'a résolument rien
donné aux Québécoises et aux
Québécois. Et nous sortons de
quatre années du régime de
Justin Trudeau qui a nui aux
intérêts du Québec. Le Bloc
pense qu'il faut proposer, avoir
des idées, être créatif et
enthousiaste et nous pensons que
l'avenir du Québec passe par la
création de richesses pour et
par l'environnement. Utiliser
notre génie, non centre de
recherche, notre incroyable
capacité d'innovation, nos
ressources naturelles hautement
diversifiées, maritimes,
forestières, agricoles, notre
énergie propre, notre structure
de petites et moyennes
entreprises uniques et enviées
ailleurs au Canada et au monde.
Nous devons utiliser tout ça
pour créer un modèle de création
de richesses pour les familles
du Québec. Un modèle qui nous
soit propre. Il nous faut par
contre pour cela détenir tous
les leviers de notre propre
développement. Il nous faut
aussi l'appui des jeunes, qu'ils
viennent avec toute la
légitimité de leur propre
responsabilité envers le futur.
Et il nous faut reconnaître dans
les gestes comme dans les mots
l'urgence climatique. C'est à
nous, c'est notre devoir de vous
convaincre que la laïcité, c'est
nous. Que le français, c'est
nous. Que les régions, c'est
nous. Quelle énergie propre,
c'est nous. Que le Québec, c'est
nous. Dans tous les cas, le Bloc
est seul pour porter ces
valeurs-là avec autant de
passion et un attachement
exclusif au Québec. Chaque élu
compte. Le meilleur scénario, ce
n'est pas d'être gouvernement,
c'est celui d'élus qui forceront
le gouvernement canadien quelque
il soit à agir pour le Québec, à
respecter, à respecter le
Québec. Le Bloc québécois a
toujours bien servi le Québec.
Même dans ces moments plus
difficiles. Aujourd'hui, une
nouvelle génération s'approprie
le Bloc québécois. Je vous
invite à aller rencontrer vos
candidates et vos candidats du
Bloc québécois partout au
Québec. Je vous invite à
découvrir des candidates et des
candidats qui vont porter votre
voix à vous toutes et tous. Des
gens qui vous ressemblent, des
gens en qui vous allez vous
reconnaître. Vous allez vous
reconnaître dans les candidats
et les candidates du Bloc
québécois parce que le Québec,
c'est nous. Merci.
Je peux pas croire que j'ai été
si clair.
- Bonjour. Comme vous savez, il
y a plus de députés du Bloc
depuis la vague orange, que
pensez-vous faire?
- Je ne sais pas s'il y a une
résistance des électeurs du
Québec. On l'a tellement répété
que ça finit par devenir vrai.
Comme si les gens qui vivent
dans la grande région de Québec
étaient différents des autres
Québécois dans leur valeur et
leur langue et leurs
aspirations, leurs besoins
économiques et l'attachement à
l'environnement. Les gens de
Québec sont au moins autant que
n'importe qui d'autre
entièrement et totalement
québécois. Ce que l'on propose
va toucher toutes les québécois
et tous les Québécois alors moi,
je refuse cette espèce de
distinction et je pense que les
derniers mois ont montré très
clairement la volonté du Bloc
québécois d'être aussi fort,
fier et présent à Québec que sur
l'ensemble du territoire.
- Il n'y a pas de mystère Québec
pour vous?
- Non, il y a une grande volonté
de séduire Québec.
- Les conservateurs sont très
bien implantés à Québec. Sur
quel dossier pensez-vous
vraiment vous pouvoir les
contrecarrer?
- C'est l'ensemble des dossiers.
Je pense que les conservateurs
ont profité de l'espèce de
vacuum que cela avait créé sauf
qu'on va l'occuper le terrain,
on va occuper les enjeux, on va
parler du port et de la
juridiction de Québec pour les
infrastructures, on va parler de
la crise, de la pénurie de main-
d'oeuvre, on va parler de la
demande d'une immigration qui va
être francisée et compétente
pour la région de Québec. Les
enjeux de la région de Québec
dans un contexte où c'est
particulièrement prospère, les
enjeux, c'est de soutenir les
initiatives et la volonté des
gens de la région et des
autorités de la région et il
n'est pas accessoire de
mentionner du gouvernement du
Québec qui siège ici dans la
région et qui est notre seul
gouvernement national dans notre
seul le Parlement national.
- Depuis presque 10 ans, le bloc
québécois a à peine une petite
partie de la balance du pouvoir,
qu'est-ce qui vous fait penser
que cette fois-ci, les québécois
vont vraiment avoir plus
l'impression que le Bloc
québécois peut les représenter
est représenté comme vous dîtes
leurs valeurs?
C'est sûr que ça va marcher et
qu'on va avoir la balance du
pouvoir, on ne le sait pas.
Mais on a l'honneur et le
plaisir de faire une offre
politique avec le désir de le
faire en souriant avec
enthousiasme, avec une nouvelle
génération de candidates et de
candidats. On ne connaît pas la
réponse des Québécoises et des
Québécois. On le saura le 21
octobre. Ceux qui étaient là
avant nous peuvent le dire, le
bloc québécois qui est offert
aux électeurs du Québec
aujourd'hui est très différent.
Le temps a passé et nous nous
sommes renouvelés. Il est très
différent de celui que l'on a
connu auparavant. Après avoir eu
des contacts, avoir accordé la
confiance comme ils l'ont fait
aux libéraux et au NPD, il est
tout à fait possible que les
Québécois disent : nous n'avons
jamais été aussi bien servis
qu'avec une forte députation
à Ottawa.
- Yves François Blanchet lance
sa première campagne électorale
comme chef. Il a fait preuve de
modestie. Il a dit : nous aurons
des devoirs à faire pour faire
la démonstration que nous serons
utiles à Ottawa. Une petite
synthèse de vos impressions.
- C'était un très long discours.
Il a fait la liste d'épicerie.
Ce qui m'a frappé, il a salué le
gouvernement de la 4 dès le
début. En effet, il s'attache à
la CAQ.
Il parle de la forte députation
du bloc à une autre époque. Mais
à l'époque, le Parti Québécois
était très fort. Il y a eu
l'échec du lac Meech.
M. Parizeau était à la tête du
Parti Québécois.
Il y avait une dynamique qui
était là. C'est peu dire. J'ai
l'impression que cette petite
phrase, ils la disaient plus
pour son aile Martine Ouellette
qui reste encore. Mais ce ne
sera pas le thème dominant de sa
campagne.
- Je retrouve les ex.
Françoise Boivin, bonjour à
vous.
Qu'allez-vous surveiller au
cours de cette campagne.
- Je vais essayer de voir si ce
que l'on a pu voir, une campagne
électorale, cela a son
importance. Chacun des scénarios
qui se sont produits aux
élections de 2011- 2015
n'était pas prévisible
dès le départ.
Il y a une belle bataille à les
l'échelle nationale.
C'est la guerre de tranchées.
Vous vous posez la question sur
le NPD au Québec. Qu'est-ce qui
va se passer avec 39 députés
présentement. Moi, je pense
sérieusement que Jagmeet Singh
ne le dira jamais mais a mis le
x sur les 14 députés du Québec
sachant fort bien qu'il laisse
cela entre les mains d'Alexandre
Boulerice et la candidate dans
Laurier Sainte-Marie pour sauver
des sièges. Il va se concentrer
sur les 25 sièges restants et
peut-être espérer en Colombie-
Britannique de capitaliser sur
la faiblesse des verres au
niveau organisationnel, au
niveau des déclarations
incroyables des deux dernières
journées qui montrent contre le
concept d'un intérêt pour les
électeurs et la réalité de
quelque chose de solide sur le
terrain, c'est autre chose. Le
bloc aura à démontrer que cette
offre qu'ils ont à offrir, à
travers un parti qui a encore
une raison d'être, je ne suis
pas convaincu que les Québécois
sont là après les avoir
abandonné en cours de route.
- Michael Fortier.
Qu'allez-vous surveiller au
cours des 40 prochains jours.
- Moi, je vais me concentrer sur
les chefs.
M. Singh clairement joue sa
carrière dans les prochains
jours. Il n'a pas été capable
jusqu'à présent de s'affirmer.
Il a une histoire personnelle
remarquable. Il y a eu beaucoup
d'écueils dans sa vie. Il n'a
pas été capable de traduire cela
de façon à faire une connexion
dans l'électorat. C'est un homme
qui pourrait faire la
différence. M. Sheer, pour lui,
c'est sûr que le pouvoir paraît
à sa portée. En même temps, il
ne pourrait pas perdre. La
réalité, c'est qu'il y a trop de
conservateurs qui se révèlent à
lui pour détester M. Trudeau.
Non seulement il pense que M.
Trudeau ébat table, il pense
qu'il doit être battu. Je ne
suis pas sûr que le parti
conservateur aura un grand
pardon si M. Sheer n'a pas au
moins une victoire minoritaire.
Quant à M. Trudeau, j'ai juste
capté une partie de son point de
presse. Ce n'est pas le même
homme qu'il y a quatre ans.
On disait qu'il défendait son
bilan. Ce n'est pas la même
chose. Je l'ai fait en deux
campagnes, tu peux attaquer est
une campagne où tu joues la
trappe à la Jacques Lemaire.
Pendant 40 jours, c'est très
difficile.
- De façon générale, sur tous
les chefs, ou en êtes-vous.
- Je ne suis pas d'accord de
dire que le bloc québécois a eu
des bons résultats après Meech.
Les libéraux étaient au pouvoir
à Québec. Ça tient à autre
chose. En tout temps, il faut
affirmer ce que l'on est. Le
bloc, ne pas faire comme M.
Trudeau vient de la faire dans
sa conférence de presse.
Il a dit que pour l'instant, ça
veut dire quoi?
Il y a 70 % des Québécois et des
Québécoises qu'il approuve. Mais
après la campagne, surveillez-
moi bien. Il fait ce qu'il fait
avec la loi 99.
Le Québec peut décider
de son avenir.
- Est-ce que le chef du bloc va
pouvoir engranger?
Est-ce que nécessairement les
gens vont dire oui, il faut
voter pour le bloc.
- Pourquoi le fédéral et dans la
cour suprême avec un mémoire en
anglais. C'est de l'hypocrisie.
Même façon lorsque M. Trudeau se
pose en progressiste.
Un progressiste qui n'impose pas
la TPS aux industries
numériques, ce n'est pas une
nouvelle taxe. Et je termine en
disant qu'un progressiste qui
parle de paix mais qui vend des
armes à une dictature comme
l'Arabie Saoudite, on peut s'en
passer. Pour moi, le programme
qui correspond le plus au
Québec, aux Québécoises, qui
répond aux décisions unanimes,
c'est le bloc.
- Très bien.
- Il y a beaucoup de
contradictions. J'aime les gens
qui sont clairs. Les Verts,
il ne dise pas qu'il n'y a pas
d'usine d'épuration à Victoria.
- Rapidement, je veux quand même
que vous me parliez d'un défi
pour Yves François Blanchet. Ce
ne sont pas les prairies
verdoyantes non plus.
Il met la barre haute.
Ce n'est pas évident.
- J'ai été analyste et député
lors du congrès conservateur. Le
bloc faisait 20 %. On disait que
ça n'avait pas de bon sens. Tous
les analystes disaient que quand
ils auront 20 députés, ce sera
très beau. Ça n'a pas été le
cas. En juin 2003, le bloc était
à 20 %. Paul Martin à 60 %.
Le scandale des commandites
n'est pas devenu tout seul. On
gagne toujours pour une raison
et on perd toujours pour une
raison.
- M. Trudeau se dit quoi en
cette journée numéro un?
Il y a des acquis?
S'il arrive à se poser comme le
chef progressiste, c'est
jouable?
- Je pense que c'est un bon
départ. C'est important pour
Justin Trudeau de bien classer
son narratif. De faire poser la
question. C'est entre lui et les
conservateurs. C'est un défi
pour le bloc de s'inscrire dans
la mouvance. Quand tu as un
bilan à défendre, même si tu es
fier de ton bilan, c'est ce
qu'il y a une partie de la
population qui va vouloir
magasiner. Alors le grand défi
pour M. Trudeau, ce sera durant
les 40 prochaines journées.
C'est de regarder en avant, de
proposer ce qu'il veut faire. De
démontrer au progressiste que ça
demeure le meilleur choix des
autres partis politiques. Je
comprends le bloc québécois de
vouloir insister sur la loi 21.
Oui, on parle de l'intervention
de M. Trudeau. M. Sheer, ce
n'était pas évident. Il patinait
sur comment intervenir ou non
sur la question. L'ensemble des
autres partis politiques ont
essentiellement la même
position. Alors à suivre la
place que ça va prendre. Je
considère que la question des
inégalités demeure fondamentales
au-delà des enjeux.
- Michael Fortier, quel est
l'enjeu qui va faire une
différence durant la campagne.
- Il y en a trop!
- Deux ou trois.
- Il y a plusieurs campagnes
dans cette campagne. Gilles, il
se présente dans quel comté? Je
m'ennuyais du Gilles objectif!
- Je suis objectif!
- Je ne veux pas débattre avec
Gilles mais sérieusement, il y a
beaucoup de campagne au Canada.
On regarde à travers le prisme
du Québec. Il va y avoir des
campagnes un peu partout. Ce qui
est intéressant au Québec,
Gilles a raison. Ils veulent
faire des gains au Québec. M.
Trudeau pense en faire. Le seul
qui n'en fera pas c'est
probablement de Jagmeet Singh.
Il faut regarder un peu plus
large que regarder ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur du Québec.
- Tout à fait. Michael a raison.
On regarde le Québec mais il y a
des batailles excitantes qui
s'en viennent en Atlantique.
M. Trudeau, il faut être
logique. Il est à 167 sièges. Ça
ne prend pas grand-chose pour
basculer. S'en aller dans le
rayon des gouvernements
minoritaires. Ça ne prend pas
tant de sièges que cela. Il y en
avait à peine 30 en 2015.
Il a fait un saut prodigieux.
La vague Trudeau n'existait pas
dans les premières semaines de
campagne. C'est une courte
campagne. Il faudra voir comment
tout cela va se transposer
sur le terrain.
Ce sera intéressant de voir les
autres candidats.
- Je vous bouscule.
Vous serez le vendredi à 17
heures à un panel. Et à la
soirée électorale. On va suivre
la campagne ensemble. Merci pour
votre participation ce midi. À
très bientôt.
Un dernier tour de table. 20
secondes chacun. C'est quand
même excitant.
Ce n'est pas joué.
- Les gens se décident
de plus en plus tard.
- On disait que le départ
compte.
Où est le chef de l'opposition
officielle?
- Il aurait dû parler
normalement après.
M. Sheer finira par parler un
jour. Il a peut-être manqué un
petit rendez-vous. Merci à toute
l'équipe. Merci à Ottawa.
C'est lancé, c'est parti. Un
débat le 10 octobre prochain.
Un en français et en anglais
avant le vote du 21 octobre.
À très bientôt, 17 heures.